[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette émission
spéciale en cette journée nationale des
mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions
aujourd'hui bonjour célia et bonjour à
tous oui c'était il ya 21 ans la france
devenait le premier pays du monde à
reconnaître les esclavages comme crime
contre l'humanité
aujourd'hui 10 mai le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron va présider une
cérémonie républicaine dans le jardin du
luxembourg émission spéciale à suivre en
direct sur les chaînes du réseau
outre-mer la première france info
tv5monde france3 et bien évidemment
public sénat remet alors vous l'avez
compris c'est un dispositif spécial que
nous vous proposons aujourd'hui on va
suivre et commenter cette cérémonie avec
nos invités en plateau on vous les
présente dans un instant et on parlera
avec notamment de la question de la
transmission de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé auprès des jeunes et du
grand public oui et donc pourra en
parler pour suivre pour analyser pour
commenter cette cérémonie on a le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
nadia weinstein bonjour vous êtes
professeur agrégé d'histoire responsable
éducation à la fondation pour la mémoire
de l'esclavagé martial foucault bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
politologue titulaire de la chaire d
outre-mer à sciences po paris marie
albane de suremain maître de conférences
en histoire contemporaine bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes l'auteur du livre
enseigner les traite les esclavages les
abolitions et leur héritage c'est aux
éditions karthala et cécile vidal
bonjour bouge est historienne directrice
d'études à le hss votre dernier livre
paru au seuil les mondes de l' esclavage
une histoire comparée on voit à l'écran
tiens on va commencer avec vous si vous
le voulez bien cécile vidal le 10 mai
est une date allait relativement neuve
de notre calendrier républicain très
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on commémore
aujourd'hui l'abolition la seconde
abolition de l'esclavagé puis surtout la
loi taubira en fait l'adoption de
le fait de reconnaître en effet
les traite des esclaves
les esclavages comme des crimes contre
l'humanité mais est ce que c'est une
date qui parle au grand public parce que
quand on pense dilemme on pense plutôt
10 mai 1981 dans l'imaginaire flirt eric
bon je pense que de ce fait elle est
devenue depuis son instauration
l'instauration des journées de
commémoration une journée relativement
populaire qui associe à de très
nombreuses manifestations
qui donne lieu à des expositions à des
émissions comme aujourd'hui par exemple
et ça contribue considérablement à la
transmission de l'histoire et de la
mémoire des traits de l'esclavagé des
abolitions c'est une date qui est
inédite au monde
c'est quelqu'un veut réagir et de films
peut-être que le dit mais c'est quoi
c'est une spécificité vraiment c'est
très français
oui il me semble c'est très français
c'est l'anniversaire de l'adoption de la
loi par le parlement effectivement par
l'assemblée où la part de l'édition est
la promulgation s'est faite le 21 mai
mais elle a été votée le 10 mai c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une date
effectivement qui n'est pas trop connoté
à l'origine et qui permet finalement de
réunir de réunir des mémoires diverses
et de fédérer dans un discours
historique commun qui peut être mis en
partage peut-être plutôt que de choisir
une date qu'il y aurait des connotations
très forte pour certains moins pour
d'autres voilà donc c'est sans doute un
choix qui a permis de créer du commun et
comme le disait ces sites vidal de créer
une date qui maintenant peut réunir et
qui s'est instaurée quand même dans
l'espace public et qui commence est
connu c'est une date officielle on l'a
dit emmanuel macron va présider cette
cérémonie comme ses prédécesseurs avant
lui est ce que le fait le président de
la république soit présent ça change
quelque chose et ça donne une autre
valeur à cette cérémonie
évidemment within en termes de cohésion
justement et de symbolique la présence
du président de la république en effet
celle dit quelque chose de de la manière
dont l'état regarde cette histoire et
encourage son inscription dans
l'histoire nationale
martial foucault justement vous qui êtes
politologue cette présence
présidentielle sa marque quelque chose
oui aux filles plusieurs types de
présence présidentielle il ya une
présence active lorsque l'exécutif prend
la parole parce que ça donne du poids et
bien sûr ça contribue à la portée
symbolique et aussi puisque le thème de
l'émission et sur la transmission il ya
des éléments importants qui peuvent être
voilà transmis par part par la parole de
l'exécutif puis il ya une participation
plus passive voilà on celle
d'aujourd'hui où un président de la
république ne prend pas la parade
discours effectivement qui comme et
dernière la seule fois où emmanuel
macron a pris la parole c'était en 2019
et est donc forcément s'est interrogé il
faut aussi comprendre pourquoi le
président républicain moment où il vient
d'être réélu ne décide pas de faire de
cette la pause due à un moment et aussi
peut-être une inscription sur un
quinquennat qui qui n'a pas forcément
été à la hauteur des tout cas des
attentes dans dans les sociétés
ultramarines sur l'engagement de ce
gouvernement on va tout de suite
retrouvé martimbault merck et dans les
jardins du luxembourg sous le soleil
martin expliquez-nous comment cette
cérémonie va se dérouler
alors ça va être une cérémonie assez
courte une quarantaine de minutes est
assez sobre finalement comme d'habitude
mais mais il ya quand même une
différence notable par rapport aux
années d'avant très belle les années
commises alors les restrictions c'est un
peu terminé du coup maintenant il y aura
plus de monde va vous emmener au coeur
de deux là où va se dérouler cette
cérémonie il y aura plus de monde que
les années d'avant le président de la
république sera présent bien sûr au
centre de cette tribune officielle au
premier rang il sera entouré emmanuel
macron de certains deux de ses ministres
à leurs trois étaient annoncés
finalement ils seront une bonne
quinzaine et puis le rader des élus qui
seront invités des sénateurs le premier
d'entre eux est évidemment le président
du sénat gérard larcher et quelques
invités de marque également mais le gros
de ses tribunes vous les voyez il y en a
pas mal des tribunes quand même il ya
pas mal de place aux quatre coins de
cette cérémonie le retraité ses tribunes
seront garnies de jeunes car c'est la
jeunesse qui sera au centre de cette
cérémonie des jeunes des haies
d'écoles élémentaires de collèges de
lycées qui seront qui seront présents
alors comment ça va se passer ils seront
grands 401 ces jeunes comment ça va se
passer la cérémonie devrait débuter aux
alentours de 16 heures qu'on arrivera le
chef de l'état il ne va pas prendre la
parole emmanuel macron l'elysée nous l'a
encore confirmé il y à il ya quelques
minutes pas de parole ni à cette tribune
ni à notre niekro mai mais il va écouter
des textes qui seront prononcées par ces
ses élèves de collèges de lycées qui ont
remporté la flamme de l'égalité ce prix
de la flamme de l'égalité avec un lien à
chaque fois c'est les femmes les femmes
dans la lutte contre l' esclavage après
ces tests il y aura le temps du
recueillement un dépôt de gerbe de
fleurs devant ce monument que l'on
commence à connaître dans les jardins du
sénat il est là depuis quelques années
en hommage à la traiter et au aux
esclaves aux victimes de l'esclavagé et
puis une marseillaise chantée par les
plus les jeunes que vous voyez juste
derrière des élèves de de bondy qui vont
venir clore cette cérémonie le début
c'est donc à ces heures normalement en
tout cas et vous l'avez dit sous un très
beau soleil dans ses jardins du
luxembourg
merci martin on ne disais à l'instant et
martin nous le rappelait martial
foucault le président de la république
qui sera revenu mais en tout cas il ne
prendra pas la parole lors de cette
cérémonie est-ce que selon vous c'est ça
signifie quelque chose au regard
justement du résultat des élections des
récentes élections présidentielles et du
résultat les manuels macron dans ces
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
je sais pas s'il faut faire une relation
de cause à effet de la défaite du parti
du président de la république à la fois
gérer au premier tour et au deuxième
tour parce que c'est le caractère et
dont
les principaux bassins de population
antilles guyane la réunion effectivement
jean luc mélenchon est arrivé largement
en tête si l'élection présidentielle se
déroulait au premier tour jean luc
mélenchon aurait été élu par ses quatre
territoires dès le premier tour et puis
au second tour c'est marine le pen qui
est largement en tête est-ce qu emmanuel
macron ne prend pas la parole parce que
son résultat dans les outre mer est
extrêmement décevant comparativement à
je crois que l'effectif dont la
légitimité du président de la république
est et n'est pas totale dans dans les
outre-mer alors illustre mari font
peut-être mettre de côté la poésie
française et et la nouvelle calédonie où
il réalise de très bons scores moi je
pense que c'est surtout ces événements
des derniers mois qui notamment dans les
antilles et en guyane qui ont conduit
président de la république à perdre
énormément en crédit politique
crise sanitaire et puis plus largement
crise crise sociale parce que pour la
réunion s'est pas seulement une question
de crise sanitaire d'ailleurs ces mêmes
la question du passage final de la
vaccination n'a pas été un sujet aussi
important et aussi
explosif que dans les antilles sont
question de crise sociale depuis au
moins l'hiver 2019 je crois qu'on a
oublié dans l'hexagone le poids de la
crise des gilets jaunes à la réunion n'a
semblé dire que ça se passait que dans
l'hexagone mais la réunion c'était c'est
un sujet qui ne cesse d'être encore
encore présents donc il agirait à un
ensemble de on a beaucoup comparé ce
terme de colère mais c'est vrai que les
colères plutôt sanitaire en dans les
antilles en guyane et colère sociale et
couple est couplé à une question qui
ramène et je pense que cette journée
très intéressante parce que on voit bien
qu'il ya pas eu unanimité sur le symbole
de cette journée de commémoration et
notamment dans les antilles est
passablement une demande de
commémoration et une demande de
réparation et la réparation
conduit à rediscuter des éléments liés à
la fois la cherté de la vie à la
question de bien sûr des inégalités
sociales il ya une loi égalité réelle
depuis février 2017 mais pour un certain
nombre de militants peut-être plus
radicaux à gauche dans les antilles
l'égalité réelle s'est pas demandé ce
que l'on veut c'est tout simplement une
réparation au regard 2
je dirais pas seulement les esclavages
mais la période donc l'esclavagisme
duran duran sais si je comprends bien ce
que vous dites c'est que se dit mais
c'est aussi une date politique vous êtes
d'accord avec ça
certainement c'est une date politique
mais c'est vrai que pour moi qui
m'occupe de d'éducation je trouve que
c'est surtout un formidable tremplin
pour parler justement de cette histoire
et de ses héritages et pour faire la
part belle aux aux jeunes et aux
productions des jeunes notamment dans le
cadre comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure du concours de la flamme de
l'égalité qui est un concours scolaire
national et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que il a été initié en 2016 par le
comité national pour la mémoire et
l'histoire de l'esclavagé est
en fait dès le début la remise des prix
des pour les lauréats nationaux donc
trois lauréats écoles collèges et lycées
a été associé à cette cérémonie
présidentielle si bien que pour les
jeunes c'est l'occasion aussi celle sera
aujourd'hui de pouvoir présenter des
extraits de leurs de leurs travaux en
fait qu'ils ont mené pendant l'année et
tous les enseignants sont unanimes pour
dire à quel point mener un projet pareil
avec une classe saas apporte sa porte
vraiment les jeunes c'est un sujet qui
les intéresse énormément on va revenir
un petit peu plus tard sur ce concours
de la flamme de l'égalité puisqu'on aura
avec nous deux jeunes collégiens qui ont
participé cette année et qui viendront
nous raconter justement leur projet mais
au-delà de ce concours et cette date
politique nous le thématique de cette
émission qu'on a choisi d'associer à
cette cérémonie c'est la question de la
transmission cécile vidal est ce que
c'est important justement d'avoir des
dates marqué dans le calendrier qui
permettent de véhiculer cette
transmission notamment à travers les
jeunes qui seront très présents dans le
jardin du luxembourg disait martin bost
maire
alors c'est important en effet parce que
c'est un moment de commun
alors que
dans les différents lieux où se
transmettent l'histoire et la mémoire
dans les musées à l'université dans les
écoles primaires secondaires dans les
associations
ça se passe à des moments différents là
le fait d'avoir un jour d'une journée
nationale de commémoration
ça réunit en fait potentiellement
beaucoup de gens il ya ce moment la une
un accent qui est mis sur le sujet dans
l'ensemble des territoires français en
hexagone que comme dans les dom et donc
ça c'est important en fait c'est parce
que par rapport à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est une date qui est
importante pas seulement politiquement
pour les dom la réunion les antilles
mais aussi pour l'hexagone c'est une
histoire qui est tout aussi importante
pour l'hexagone que pour les
départements et régions d'outre-mer une
histoire commune est ce qu'il faudrait
en faire un jour férié marianne ban de
suremain alors là c'est la question à
savoir effectivement il faudrait poser
la question par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'opinion publique et de l'espace public
moi ce que je retiens c'est que le dit
mais ça permet d'inscrire la date dans
l'espace public je dirais que dans
l'espace scolaire le 10 mai comme le
disait madame einstein c'est une
impulsion une impulsion mais qui peut
conduire à mener des travaux sur toute
l'année et c'est vrai que cette question
de la traiter d' esclavage et elle est
abordée à certains moments de l'année en
fonction des programmes scolaires qui
correspondent pas forcément aux 10 mai
mais il ya eu cette impulsion et puis à
cette présence dans l'espace public bon
je crois que le 10 mai ces dates a
atteint son objectif et qu elle est
clairement inscrit dans notre espace
public maintenant qu'elle attend son
objectif vous pensez qu'elle est
suffisamment connue aujourd'hui des
français alors le fait est que dans
l'espace public elle et elle est prise
en compte il ya des émissions des
commémorations des cérémonies etc et
puis à l'école il me semble qu'il a eue
cette impulsion porté notamment par les
activités autour du 10 mai et notamment
le concours de la flamme de l'égalité et
c'est ça qui est le plus important plus
que la date précise à l'école
les élèves sont en train de traiter
telle ou telle question en ce moment qui
n'est pas forcément lien avec la traite
ou l'esclavagé mais l'essentiel c'était
que ce soit bien inscrit dans les
programmes ça c'est grâce à la loi
taubira que cette place a été approfondi
mais alors j'ai dit aux gars c'est un
port des actions dans la durée sur sur
l'année puisque vous parlez de cette loi
taubira donc adopté effectivement le 10
mai
2001 qui ce qui a changé avec cette loi
dans l'enseignement de l'histoire de
l'esclavagé à l'école moi j'étais
peut-être un mauvais élèves mais je me
souviens pas vraiment avoir suivi
d'enseignements de cette histoire de l'
esclavage
pas suffisamment en tout cas
suffisamment effectivement
nous aimons à rapt et je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord qu'il n'y avait pas
rien avant la loi taubira il ya toujours
eu une place dans les programmes mais
effectivement l'article 2 de la loi de
bien vraiment c'est une prescription
d'égal en fait dit la place conséquente
que cette histoire mérite voilà après il
ya une marge d'interprétation sur cette
place conséquente mais en tout cas on
peut dire que et ça a été analysée
d'ailleurs par un pape par une étude
scientifique il ya eu véritablement un
progrès en termes d'horaires
d'être posée c'est ça dédié non les dans
leur antre de 10 à l'ancienne au g voilà
il ya un avant et un après la loi il ya
un avant et un après c'est certain alors
on va justement voir comment la
curiosité des élèves peut être suscité
sur cet enseignement comment dans les
différents départements on enseigne
parce que ça dépend aussi peut-être du
public qu'on a en face avec un reportage
qui se passe à la fois dans les deux
sèvres et en martinique reportage de
pierre lacombe et irène et monique
à droite le collège jacques roumain a
rivière pilote en martinique 1 va donc
entamer la correction de la la gauche le
collège antoine de saint-exupéry à niort
dans les deux sèvres deux classes deux
approches sur le thème de l' esclavage
au lieu de cela ils sont récupérés
d'afrique entre 300 et 450 experts
confirmés dans laquelle il fait chaud en
martinique terre de mémoire ce travail
est essentiel auprès des jeunes
générations
d'abord parce que cette histoire est la
leur et ensuite parce qu'il convient de
ne jamais oublier ce que ces hommes et
ces femmes en temps durs est
différent contre sauf qu'on leur apprend
et la réalité de l'est au biquotidien
les oublie qu voilà on est des terres de
mémoire et ce sont des choses qui ont
vraiment eu lieu vérification des acquis
question dans quelles conditions s'est
effectué la traversée des esclaves de
l'afrique vers les antilles les indices
ont entassé dans laquelle qui se bat
beaucoup d espace de vie ils sont mal
nous dit il aux banques d'hygiène qui
sont comme s'il y est comme des bêtes
des animaux
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique les
élèves de 3e du collège saint-exupéry de
niort sont un atelier l'esclavagé à
travers une émission de radio une pièce
de théâtre ou une poésie un jour
l'histoire le rendra hommage peut-être
dans les livres d'image dans la justice
et le respect après tant de douleur
l'esclave âge c'est une période mc il
faut pas l'oublier parce que ça peut ça
existe toujours l'histoire c'est la
mémoire et puis surtout c'est la
construction citoyenne c'est de
l'ouverture d'esprit salive qu'on
s'enferme et qu'on aille vers les
extrêmes c'est quelque chose qui est moi
je leur dit faut être ouvert il faut
comprendre le passé pour peut-être aussi
voir autrement le présent
l'enseignement de l'esclavagé de la
traite négrière deux mois encore trop
confidentielle dans les programmes
scolaires surtout dans l'hexagone où
l'appréciation pourrait se résumer en
trois mots peut mieux faire
cécile vidal qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir justement de cette façon dont
est enseigné l'histoire de l'exclavage
on a vu il a deux publics différents à
la fois en martinique à la fois niort
donc des élèves qui sont sensibilisés 2
par leur propre histoire à cette grande
histoire et d'autres qui le connaissent
moins cette histoire alors en effet les
programmes ne sont pas les mêmes
exactement sur le sujet dans l'hexagone
et dans les dom et puis selon les
niveaux en fait comme un an collège met
en revanche en seconde entre seconde
générale et technologique et seconde
professionnelle c'est assez différent la
fondation pour la mémoire d' esclavage a
fait une note sur le sujet pointant le
fait que c'est bien mieux enseigner en
seconde professionnelle par exemple que
dans d'autres niveaux comme si le public
de cette filière était plus destiné à
entendre cette histoire que les autres
qui pose pas mal de problèmes en fait
dans la manière avec des origines qui
pourrait laisser entendre qu'ils
semblent de contrer cette liste vous
pourrez faire cette interprétation
voilà mais néanmoins assez présent quand
même de manière importante en quatrième
en seconde
dans les différentes filières ensuite ça
pourrait l'être dans d'autres niveaux et
le la question c'est comment on en scène
cette histoire et quelle interprétation
au fait de cette histoire comment on la
présente plus que le son existence ou
non sa présence ou non dans les
programmes et c'est là toute la
différence on était en formation
d'enseignants du secondaire il hier et
en décryptant ses programmes et en
réfléchissant à comment on doit
enseigner et est à l'heure actuelle
c'est vraiment une
manière une façon d'envisager ces
questions par le haut de manière très
économique pas beaucoup d'histoire
sociale une histoire qui n'est pas
tellement centrée sur les esclaves eux
mêmes donc voilà donc c'est plutôt dans
le sens de la manière de l'enseigné
qu'on devrait faire des progrès 15h19 on
la cérémonie devrait débuter autour de
16h 16h10 on va tout de suite retrouvé
martin bost maire qui est dans les
jardins du luxembourg martin vous êtes
avec une professeur des écoles c'est ça
c'est à nous
exactement parce que vous savez il ya
400 élèves en tout 400 jeunes qui seront
au centre de cette cérémonie soit dans
les tribunes pour assister soit
activement pour participer à la
cérémonie ce sera le cadet des élèves de
cm2 de l'école immaculée-conception de
saint denis de la réunion avec leur
professeur de cm2 cynthia vantaux
vous allez chanter tout à l'heure
pour aussi c'est une façon vous avez
trouvez vous pour transmettre un peu
l'histoire à vos élèves de cm2 le champ
tout à fait alors avec ma collègue
nathalie naboulet nous sommes allés en
classe patrimoine dans le cirque de
cilaos qui est donc classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco donc
aller dans ces cas cependant ce site
c'était faire découvrir aux enfants la
toponymie de lille pourquoi en fait si
l'on gagne en dénombre d'esclaves du
coup donc cilaos dimitile salsa nazi et
à travers cette enquête dont on a voulu
transmettre l'histoire de l'exclavage
donc chez nous le marronnage en
particulier donc c'est à dire la fuite
des esclaves donc depuis le littoral
jusqu'à donc les montagnes escarpées
inaccessible donc la route n'existait
pas à l'époque déjà aujourd'hui pour y
aller nous il nous faut faire 400 virage
les enfants compris par ce chemin en
fait cet acte de liberté que de refuser
l'oppression c'était de la résistance et
donc montrer comment vivait ses experts
à l'époque comment il était traité donc
ça a été un projet musical donc c'est ce
qu'on a choisi en fait un clip musical
que vous avez tout à leur chanter a
capella du coup chanter a capella donc
ma classe a fait la partie donc de la
chanson et la case nam nam ou les a
illustré est monté le clip vidéo que
malheureusement pas on peut voir du coup
sur internet mais la sauce aujourd'hui
ce sera a cappella donc la chanson
uniquement est ce que vous les sentez
réceptifs en classe ces élèves de cm2
donc encore assez jeune finalement est
ce que vous les sentez réceptif quant à
cette histoire
en tout ça fait parce que comme si notre
héritage donc à la réunion n'a été
marqué fortement par l'histoire de
l'exclavage les enfants en fait c'est
dans les livres d'histoire dans notre
programme nous n'avons pas forcément
beaucoup de choses de la réunion mais on
a quand même un jour spécial chez nous
donc si le 20 décembre donc le 10 mai
pour vous ou non travaillons pas c'est
férié et nous célébrons justement cette
fête de la liberté et en travaillant
avec l'artiste joël manglou on a écrit
cette chanson du coup pour raconter
notre histoire de longues heures pour
les enfants que ce soit accessible et
ont raconté du coup cette quête vers la
liberté et ce combat vous êtes bien
placé pour me répondre on parle souvent
des des manuels scolaires qu'on doit
peut être enrichie en histoire locale à
la réunion mais c'est pareil dans le
reste des outre-mer est ce qu'il ne faut
pas aussi davantage former les gens
comme vous les professeurs pour
transmettre ce qui demain transmettront
à l'infection peut-être que ça manque un
peu de formations puisque nous mêmes
pour faire cette histoire donc on va se
former nous mêmes donc les élèves on a
cherché dans l'icône hotech des images
d'archivés du coup pour ailleurs me
raconter cette histoire de l' esclavage
effectivement dans les manuels scolaires
actuellement la très peu de à part le
tab un tableau célèbre de billard c'est
tout ce qu'il ya sur la programmation de
la liberté voilà c'est que ça se résume
à un tableau célèbre et
voilà s'il faut faire des recherches
dans les archives merci on a envie de
construire justement c'est des traces du
passé mais pour avancer dans le passé -
pour l'avenir il faut connaître notre
passé voilà c'est ce que j'ai envie de
finir merci on vous entendra tout à
l'heure donc en direct chanter tous les
quatre je crois que vous représentez un
peu votre classe
de l'école immaculée-conception vous
entendra vous êtes parmi les 400 jeunes
qui sont présents ici parce que c'est
vous finalement qui demain transmettront
encore plus jeunes
est ce que finalement les professions il
faut les accompagner aussi dans la
transmission de cette science là on a vu
un professeur des écoles de la réunion
donc on parlait public plus concernés
sans doute les tel ce qui est pas
forcément le cas de tous les élèves et
de tous les enseignants alors comme le
disait c'est si évident à tout à l'heure
c'est en apparence un public plus
concernés parce qu'effectivement il ya
une histoire vécue sur le territoire de
l esclavage comme dans les autres outre
mer mais cette histoire elle concerne
vraiment toute la france et aussi bien
on peut accompagner les enseignants
justement à découvrir cette histoire sur
l'hexagone à travers notamment la
découverte des archives des services
d'archivés il ya énormément de choses
sur tout le territoire français et pas
seulement dans les franges atlantique je
pense par exemple remarquable dossier
pédagogique d un fils départemental du
loiret qui est en ligne voilà dans le
loiret aussi on était concerné quand il
ya des raffineries de sucre à orléans
quand il ya des fabriques de textile
destinés à être des marchandises de
traite ça ça peut concerner les élèves
dans leur dans leur enclos balma d'un
média est effectivement cette demande
d'accompagnement elle est forte on sait
ce à quoi on s'emploie aussi à la
formation est vraiment un tapage dans la
formation on va parler avec des élèves
puisqu'ils nous ont rejoints
on a le plaisir d'accueillir ines soit
tina et timothée sivas bonjour à tous
les deux vous avez participé à un
concours cette année le concours de la
flamme pour l'égalité comment ça s'est
passé timothée
bien bien bien on a une prof qui nous a
beaucoup aidés dans nos devoirs nous a
bien guidé alors comment ça se passe
peut être racontée un peu ce que c'est
que ce concours qu'est-ce que vous avez
dû faire qu'est-ce que vous avez proposé
à ce concours consiste à faire des
hommes artistiques ou
culturelles et cetera
en mémoire de l'esclavagé
voilà donc on a pris des heures de cours
pour le faire
vous devez présenter un projet c'est ça
c'est ça exactement 2 un projet
quelconque de notre choix c'était quoi
votre projet à bon moi j'ai créé une
pièce de théâtre avec mon groupe donc à
une pièce de théâtre qui parle d'un
esclave ou achetés aux antilles en 1791
donc dans la pièce d'âtre on raconte sa
vie la cruauté de l' esclavage
de par des gestes des répliques
de l'époque vous avez également un
projet dans ce concours de l'égalité
mais alors nous on a mis en scène une
émission radio et dont c'est ici dans
cette émission radio il y avait trois
personnes dont des historiens
on avait utilisés fin on avait pris
aussi la conservatrice on avait une
camarade bureau de la conservatrice du
musée de nantes sur l esclavage et donc
par le biais de ces personnages nous
avons voulu mettre en avant les les
opinions qu'on différentes personnes sur
l'esclavagé de nos jours c'est une
histoire pendant que vous connaissiez
avant d'entre d'eux te travailler cette
matière avec votre professeur
on en avait parlé en quatrième lanceur
dans notre
dents
en classe mais sinon
pas plus que ça non pas puisque ça mais
vous témoin t on à un peu survolé le
sujet à vrai dire
ça a duré une semaine bien voulu que ça
dure
vous avez appris quoi qu'est ce que
peut-être même ce concours qu'elle qui
vous a apporté intellectuellement bas il
nous a il nous a apporté la culture
générale c'est important de savoir la
vie des esclaves à l'époque même nous
nous ne pouvons pas l'imaginer parce que
c'était vraiment très cruel
et voilà ça a permis de travailler en
groupe sur un sujet qu'on a abordé en
quatrième et qu'on a approfondi en
troisième alors on va voir justement une
autre illustration ce concours avec des
élèves du lycée de la tourelle à
sarcelles c'est un reportage de pierre
lacombe et albane lucien
ils étaient au nombre de cent hommes ou
femmes de différents âges tous occupés à
creuser des fosses dans une pièce de
cannes et la plupart nu ou coup la broye
manque d'assurance et l'eurasie et
hésitant ces élèves de seconde du lycée
de la tourelle à sarcelles travail sur
l'esclavagé les notions sont un peu
lointaine et confuse mais elles sont
compensées par beaucoup d'ardeur et d'
enthousiasme sont vraiment enthousiastes
heurte surtout le projet qu'on fait et
en particulier sur esclavage pour la
neige comme touchés par cette question
est intéressé
d'origine haïtienne africaine
outre-mer donc avant attaché à ce que
sont là et même leurs parents qu'on a
consulté au mois de septembre nous ou
même remercier pour cette initiative et
cette initiative c'est la participation
à la septième édition de la flamme de
l'égalité un concours national ouvert
chaque année à plusieurs milliers
d'élèves partout en france et qu'est ce
qu'il fait il surveille très j'y serai
qui va les hommes et les femmes qui sont
les esclaves exactement il est important
de se rappeler car ce qui s'est passé
avant nous suit jusqu'à lors du jour j
prix et j'ai pas ce fait partie de notre
histoire l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
intéressant et enrichissant à la fin on
apprend beaucoup de choses des temps les
plus anciens jusqu'à l'époque
contemporaine
ces élèves n'ont pas choisi le plus
facile cette frise chronologique c'est
le point de départ de leur vidéo elle
raconte en quatre minutes les
abominations de l' esclavage à travers
les siècles ils ont étudié en quatrième
et puis on le revoit en seconde en
seconde on n'a qu'une heure d'histoire
géographie donc ce qui est peu pour
traiter d'un sujet aussi important et en
même temps il ya aussi parfois pour
l'enseignant la question de la réception
comment ils vont recevoir le discours
qu'on va nous leurs données et le
travail qu'on va leur faire faire sur
cette question de mémoire vive parce que
c'est encore une mémoire qui actuelle
c'est important pour leur mémoire
individuelle on le sent bien mais nous
on porte la mémoire collective pour leur
dire voilà il faut être sensibilisés à
toutes les formes d' esclavage
l'ancien le moderne contemporain pour
qu'ils aient aussi cette conscience de
d'inacceptable de l'oppression mêler aux
jo beaucoup n'étaient pas venues
raconter chanter interprété à chacun son
style pour exprimer son regard sur l'
esclavage l'essentiel étant de
participer pour maintenir vive la flamme
de l'égalité et ne jamais oublier ce que
ces hommes et ces femmes entend durée
inès même question qui à cathy mottez
qu'est ce que ce concours vous a apporté
ce que ça vous a donné envie d'aller
plus loin de d'aller plus loin juste en
a connaissance de cette histoire oui ça
nous donne envie d'aller plus loin d'en
apprendre plus parce que quand même on
n'en parle pas beaucoup et on en parlait
on s'en rend compte que l'on se rend
compte que ce qu'ils ont vécu c'est
quand même un abominable que enfin voilà
donc ça nous donne vraiment envie d'en
apprendre plus et
ça a suscité des vocations peut-être je
sais pas devenir historien historienne
comme ici sur ce plateau
pas forcément bah forcément
vous encore des questions pas forcément
mais peut-être que ça vous a donné vous
le disiez à l'instant envie de réfléchir
est ce que ça fait écho à l'actualité à
des choses plus contemporaine selon vous
oui mais on en parle on en parlait aussi
en classe des méthodes nouvelles de
d'esclavagé ce qu'on appelle d'esclavagé
moderne donc on en parlait et ça nous
donne envie de nous intéresser justement
est ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
le cas aussi pour vous thimoté oui
exactement
à notre cour on a quelques chiens 210
millions d'enfants aujourd'hui
sont considérés comme des esclaves
dans les pays andins pakistan par
exemple
beaucoup d'enfants
fabrique des ballons pour des marques
assez connus comme adidas ou puma les
fèves de cacao ont ramassé par des
enfants en afrique aussi en côte
d'ivoire et
c'est cette dimension actualité qui vous
a beaucoup marqué c'est ça le fait que
ce soit toujours actuelle aujourd'hui à
l'heure où on parle oui ça il sait
peut-être pas tout à fait la même
histoire effectivement cécile vidal mais
en tout cas on voit que ça cette date
elle peut créer des liens y compris avec
la période contemporaine absolument la
chose importante c'est que à l'heure
actuelle l'esclavagé interdit partout
dans le monde n'existe plus un pays où
l'esclavagé légal donc c'est vraiment
une différence fondamentale parce que
l'esclavagé ne peut pas exister de la
même façon quand c'est une activité
illégale mais de fait en effet c'est une
réalité extrêmement importante après se
pose la question de ce que l'on met
derrière ce terme d' esclavage moderne
et à l'heure actuelle l'escale travail
des enfants est considéré comme une
forme d esclavage parce que peuvent pas
consentir en fait à une relation de
travail imposées mais ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas donc mais on désigne
de plus en plus en fait comme des formes
in may inadmissible d'exploitation de
domination au travail notamment enfin on
les met sous le terme d' esclavage
esclavage moderne y avait le temps
j'avais une question assure sur cet
enseignement à ce qu'il est vraiment
uniforme on voit c'est ce genre
d'initiatives dans les classes qui lève
en uniforme partout en france sur tous
les territoires aujourd'hui alors non
effectivement comme
l'avait engagé tout à l'heure c'est
sylvie danny lee à des programmes
adaptés pour les outremers de façon à ce
que justement les outre mer puissent
étudier localement cette histoire dans
le cadre des programmes globaux qui sont
communs donc à tous les français il ya
une déclinaison à une adaptation
particulière pour ces territoires
d'outre-mer centré sur leur histoire
donc locale par territoire et c'est vrai
que lorsqu'on regarde ces programmes on
se dit ça serait vraiment très
intéressant que tous les français
puissent avoir accès à ces programmes de
la même façon ouais on va retrouver
martin bost maire au jardin du
luxembourg avec à vos côtés martin
george patience qanater de la guyane
georges patient sénateurs de guyane qui
me disais à l'instant qu'il ne raterait
pour rien au monde ce type de cérémonie
pourquoi selon vous cette année encore
plus que les autres c'est important pour
la maison dans ses jardins du luxembourg
écoutez
c'est déjà très important d'y être comme
je voulais dit ça fait plusieurs années
que j'y assiste je suis à ma quatorzième
année je crois que j ai assisté à 13
reprises mais cette année beaucoup plus
les autres années après tout les
enseignements que l'on doit tirer des
récente élection présidentielle
voir marine le pen remporté autant de
suffrages dans nos outre-mer quand on
connaît les liens étroits qui unissent
nos outre-mer surtout les df1 avec hull
esclavage
pour moi jusqu'à maintenant j'essaie de
trouver des raisons on en parle de votre
sanction mais c'est pour moi ce n'est
pas le cas ça a été presque un vote
d'adhésion et qui voir mes compatriotes
à bir et aux idées de le pen ça a été
vécue pour moi comme une espèce de
deux grands mâles et hélas aujourd'hui
venir commémorer j'ai invité les gens à
y venir
ne serait-ce que l'instant de la
manifestation se rappeler de ce qu'a été
l'esclave âge je pense qu' il fallait
pas être absents aujourd'hui il a je
m'adresse à vous les médias je pense que
les images qui qui qui vont être
rapportées au
aujourd'hui aux auditeurs ou
téléspectateurs
de francs être choisi pour que le
message passe très fort on n'a pas le
droit quand on est dans les outre-mer
français
de mettre un bulletin pour le
rassemblement national merci georges
patient la cérémonie va débuter dans
quelques minutes et vous la voyez cette
tribune officielle qui commence à se
garnir de plus en plus merci martin
message très politique du sénateur
georges patient on va remercier de notre
côté nos collégiens et inès et timothée
de nous avoir fait part de leur
expérience ce concours de la flamme de
l'égalité merci également à nadia ou
einstein de nous avoir accompagnés pour
cette première partie d'émission cécile
vidal vous restez avec nous on va
découvrir un peu de musique maintenant
d'ailleurs pour pour changer un petit
peu on va
retrouvez un extrait du groupe d'un
concert du groupe d'el grèce c'était le
mois dernier à paris del grèce est un
groupe de musique engagée dont le nom
n'est pas complètement anodin on y
revient dans un instant après ces
quelques notes de musique
[Musique]
comment faire sans
justement
[Musique]
battu
par mois
moi
[Musique]
non
je joue moins qu'à son
dû
ceux-là
vous laissez moi
[Musique]
son genre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
quand on
voilà pour cet extrait dont l'un des
leaders du groupe éditions de l'atelier
vous le présenter dans un instant
bonjour moi mais dassa oui bonjour
c'était pas moins à l'écran vous vous
êtes écrivain et journaliste merci
d'être avec nous parce qu'à dallas et
bonjour bonjour c'était donc vous qu'on
a vu à l'écran leader du groupe d la
grèce franck salin est aussi sur ce
plateau écrivain metteur en scène et
réalisateur
merci d'être avec nous et cécile vidal
vous êtes ici chez vous vous êtes resté
là non pas qu'elle donnait delgrès vient
de voir un extrait del rey c'est pas un
nom à nos dents expliquez nous peut-être
qu'il est et d'allégresse et pourquoi
vous avez choisi de reprendre ces noms
là louis de grèce donc on a appelé notre
groupe
voilà comme ce grand monsieur dont j'ai
découvert l'existence
tard dans ma vie alors moi je suis
d'origine guadeloupéenne né en france
hexagonale mon père est arrivé en 1958
en france et il m'a parlé louis delgrès
ce même tard comme ça de manière un
petit peu informel et puis j'ai mis ça
dans un coin de ma tête est bien des
années plus tard au moment où j'avais le
blues véritablement dans nos temps ma
vie j'avais besoin d'eux balade est de
reconnecter avec mes racines et ils
m'ont d'identité caraïbes et j'ai pensé
à ce monsieur à skis à ce qu'il avait
vécu à son sacrifice
lorsqu'il a vécu donc lui d'agréer c'est
un officier de napoléon bonaparte à
l'office et de la révolution française
nous qui s'est battu pour le vivre libre
ou mourir et qui était basée en
guadeloupe en 1802 au moment où napoléon
avait décidé de rétablir l'esclavagé
dans les antilles françaises lors comme
c'était quelqu'un qui croyait fermement
la liberté il est entré en rébellion et
après plusieurs presqu'un mois à peu
près de combat et s'ils savaient qu'ils
étaient perdus pas sûr les temps sous
l'ombre et donc il a décidé lui et tous
ses compagnons de faire sauter
l'ensemble l'habitation dans laquelle il
était évidemment tuant plus de france
est possible y compris eux mêmes donc le
sacrifice ultime
pour ses valeurs la liberté pour
lesquelles il s'était battu toute sa vie
si vous êtes identifié précisément ce
personnage là et pourquoi oui parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui qui apportait
beaucoup inité à cette notion de
créolité est quelqu'un qui est mort
debout c'est un combattant ça c'est
important pour quelqu'un qui comme moi
voilà j'ai grandi en france
métropolitaine et et voilà se sentir
antilles et en france même dans mon âge
avancé à cette époque là déjà c'était
important pour moi d'avoir cette figure
là ces figures de combattants donc j'ai
juste fait une chanson pour lui et après
ça a ouvert la porte à la possibilité de
nous mais le groupe comme ça justement
sur ce plateau on parle de transmission
est-ce que vous expliquer au public qui
edel grèce quand vous êtes en concert
justement pour transmettre un peu de
cette histoire de votre histoire
personnelle et de cette histoire avec un
grand h de la france oui absolument mais
c'est très important en fait il ya cette
chanson qu'on l'a fait pour lui
s'appelle mojo dit vous dire mourir
aujourd'hui et à chaque fois que je
présente ses chansons je dis pourquoi on
l'a fait si mehdi rouler l'occasion
maintenant puisque l'on a pensé à
tourner en 2016 et qu'on a fait une
centaine de concerts par an un peu
partout dans le monde ça veut dire qu'à
chaque fois on ajouté sans son eh bien
je dis voilà pourquoi vous faire on fait
ça et je suis vraiment ravi parce qu'il
ya des réactions partout absolument
partout dans le monde de gens qui
viennent et qui sont curieux et qui
distrait mais je ne savais pas ou alors
j'ai pas entendu parler mais qui veulent
en savoir plus donc on fait comme ça on
a notre petite pierre à l'édifice que
les gens soient au courant de ce qui
s'est passé il ya une différence
un musicien réalisateur journaliste
écrivain une différence dans la manière
de transmettre le vecteur aussi est
important
oui il faut transmettre avec tous les
vecteurs possible il faut transmettre
par les cris par la musique par le
limage le cinéma
il faut le les plasticiens aussi se sont
attaqués à cette histoire et
c'est formidable parce que il faut se
rappeler que pendant très longtemps
c'est une histoire qui était tabou moi
je suis très vieux aussi comme lui et et
moi j'étais enfant dans les années 80
adolescents voilà dans les années 80
début 90 et et en guadeloupe on pouvait
pas parler de ça on n'avait pas le droit
de parler de ça c'était tabou parce que
c'était une histoire qu'on ne
connaissait pas ou foncée interdisait à
c'est une histoire transit ranger
j'ai le sentiment qu'on conservait tout
ce qu'elle avait existé même si on se la
racontait pas mais il fallait pas en
parler parce que fallait passer à autre
chose allait passer à autre chose mais
en réalité on ne peut pas passer à autre
chose si on ne creuse pas la question et
si on ne fait pas la paix avec cette
question là et moi par exemple ça me
tourmentait tellement que j'ai fait des
études d'histoire
à l'evian masters j'ai étudié ces
questions là parce que ça me travaillait
pas ce que je me demandais pourquoi
pourquoi on ne pouvait pas parler de ça
qu'il était louis delgrès ce qu'est ce
que c'était le marronnage comment ça se
passe à sion de plantation non je
m'intéressais comme beaucoup d'autres à
cette question et heureusement j'ai pu
avoir des réponses me ce qui est
formidable aujourd'hui c'est que cette
histoire là n'est plus tabou aujourd'hui
on est sur un plateau on en parle aux
antilles en guyane à la réunion il ya
des plateaux on en parle à l'école
il y à il ya eu ici en france hexagonale
mouvement extraordinaire depuis le 23
mai 1998 et la marche silencieuse du 23
mai
dans la société civile les associations
beaucoup d'artistes d'ici aussi dans
l'hexagone se sont approprié cette
histoire donc moi je suis heureux à ma
petite échelle de voir les progrès de
cette histoire en quelques décennies et
le fait qu'on puisse en parler
aujourd'hui sur le plateau en parler de
façon générale on parlait de façon
concrète vous francs que vous écrivez
des pièces de théâtre des romans des
donc c'est par l'écriture mais à travers
des personnages du coup un carnet que
vous transmettez cette histoire vous
mohamed mellah oui vous êtes intéressé à
l'esclave furcy qu'on connaît pas
forcément où j'ai qui est un réunionnais
qui a attaqué son juste en justice parce
qu'il était esclave exactement et le
procès a duré un quart de siècle il a
fini par gagner à la cour royale de
paris
je crois
que la question de la transmission qui
est le coeur de cette émission est
fondamentale et notamment avec les
reportages que j'ai vu comment on
parlait à la jeunesse c'est ça qui est
important
et que effectivement tout ce que vous
avez dit sur le lait tous les vecteurs
de transmission toutes les pierres à
l'édifice en sont importantes moi j'ai
voulu raconter une histoire à hauteur
d'homme c'est à dire l'histoire de cet
homme il a 31 ans
et à la mort de sa mère il
comprend qu'en fait qu'il aurait dû la
peep parce que sa mère
l'affranchissement et elle ne le savait
pas ce que savaient pas lire et écrire
lui sait lire et écrire et donc raconté
à hauteur d'hommes parlant quand je vais
dans les lycées ou dans les collèges
c'est incroyable comment ils comprennent
ce que c'est que que par exemple le code
noir ou le fait juridique un esclave est
un meuble simplement en décryptant une
petite annonce à vendre esclaves etc etc
ça je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans toutes les questions
mémorielles
la question de la transmission elle et
elle est sans ça on ne peut pas avancer
c'est vrai qu'il ya des moments de
l'histoire où on trouvait tabou la
question de l' esclavage de toutes parts
aussi bien des descendants d'esclaves
que des descendants d'esclavagistes et
aujourd'hui ça commence à changer la loi
taubira a contribué
on a besoin pascal danaë dont vous
parliez de la grèce il ya quelques uns
de vecteurs comme ça deux personnages
qui illustre cette histoire de façon
concrète mais surtout ce sont des
personnages qui permettent à tout un
chacun a au niveau individuel de faire
le chemin de mémoire donc ça a été mon
cas c'est quelqu'un qui a permis de
cristalliser à la fois les difficultés
que j'avais en tant que descendant
d'esclave finalement de trouver ma place
dans la société française
mais ça a été aussi ma ma planche de
salut non je pense que ces personnages
là et chacun peut avoir le sien troubler
le sillage de mon grâce au travail des
historiens
ses personnages sont très importants
sont des personnes qui vont dans
lesquels on va placer énormément de
choses et qui permettent de dépasser
parfois ce qui peut être un certain
ressentiment parce que justement il ya
une incompréhension de de sa situation
peut être parfois enfin ça plaît
beaucoup de frustration et ces
personnages là peut être vraiment des
clés pour avancer et puis surtout comme
on disait pour les prochaines
générations permet de déverrouiller les
choses c'est si vrai ce que vous dites
tous peut-être c'était aussi une
dimension politique et une dimension
évidemment si vite être une dimension
plus politique à cet acte de création
oui c'est une dimension politique ya une
dimension politique également parce que
quand on crée on crée pour soi pour se
faire plaisir évidemment parce qu'on
aime ça mais aussi pour les autres et on
réfléchit à la façon dont
les auditeurs les spectateurs enfin les
personnes qui réceptionne sept oeuvres
d'art vont se l'approprier et qu'est-ce
qu'elle lequel qu'est ce que cette
oeuvre d'art aura comme comme réaction
comme effet sur ces personnes et est
donc l'acte de créer de créer sur le
thème de l'esclavagé effectivement n'est
pas n'est pas anodin et c'est vrai que
quand on écoute la musique de ces trente
dernières années bien de plus en plus on
entend ce thème là qui qui revient de
façon de plus en plus clair
dans l'audiovisuel aussi un peu moins
c'est peut-être parce que cela coûte un
peu plus cher mais mes et qu'on n'est
pas forcément les plis populations les
plus riches mais mais dans l'audiovisuel
aussi on voit
au cinéma à la télé ces thèmes-là qui
s'impose petit à petit et
c'est important parce que vivre ensemble
vivre ensemble ça passe aussi par là
alors qu'on voit à l'écran vous parlez
les ministres évidemment se mettre en
place pour cette cérémonie qui va
débuter dans allez une petite dizaine de
deux minutes maintenant on sait bien oui
on va d'ailleurs allé retrouver martin
bost maire dans quelques instants
justement pour évoquer cette cérémonie
et l'arrivée imminente sous-vêtements du
président de la république une cérémonie
dont la transmission fait sens aussi
vous disiez franck salin un instant
faire sens faire nation ça passe aussi
par des moments symboliques comme
celui-là martin
exactement vous voyez que depuis tout à
l'heure où on avait des tribunes vides
c'est plus le cas maintenant ça commence
à se garnir alors parmi les invités on
la perçoit déjà certains ministres
olivier ferrand gabriela talent brigitte
klinkert on a vu aussi elisabeth moreno
qui a
aujourd'hui forcément insista à une
cérémonie un peu particulière puisque
c'est sur le thème des femmes notamment
dans la lutte contre l' esclavage avec
aussi aussi une partie du livre sur la
mulâtresse solitude qui sera lui livre
d'entrée schwarz bart et de sa veuve
simone schwarz bart qui vient d'arriver
juste là que l'on aperçoit qui sera au
premier rang de de cette cérémonie de
cette tribune officielle donc ça
commence à se garnir si on tourne un
petit peu on va voir aussi que du côté
des élèves ça commence désormais plus
qu'à se garnir puisque les tribunes sont
remplies on le rappelle 400 élèves qui
viennent pour assister à cette cérémonie
certains vont y participer le président
de la république ne prendra pas la
parole on l'a dit et redit et puis il y
aura le dépôt de la gerbe de fleurs
devant cette sculpture avec des lectures
de textes et des chants tout au long de
cette cérémonie qui va donc débuter
d'ici quelques minutes avec l'arrivée
attendue des maillots macro
merci beaucoup martin où vous retrouvez
à tout à l'heure c'est une information
très fraîche emmanuel roux qui était
leur est si fine informations qu'il faut
signaler ces six vidal et des artistes
sur ce plateau vous êtes historienne on
a besoin d'art pour aussi transmettre
cette cette mémoire de cette histoire et
cette mémoire absolument c'est on
travaille nous on dialogue avec les
écrivains avec les hommes et les femmes
de tat artistes les plasticiens les
cinéastes les musiciens c'est les arts
et la littérature qui rendent sensibles
nous on essaye de comprendre interpréter
d'expliquer mais les moyens qu'on a sont
complètement différents et
et
passer par la création artistique permet
de voilà de de
penser différemment de transmettre des
émotions
attention effectivement jeudi soir doit
passer par l'émotion c'est en ça passe
pas les deux noms les deux je pense que
les deux sont nécessaires parce qu'on a
besoin de mettre l'émotion à distance
pour comprendre des choses qui sont très
difficiles à comprendre parce qu'il est
très violente et qu'on peut pas les
comprendre dans l'émotion justement et
en même temps
on a besoin aussi donc pâti et la
littérature la musique les arts
permettent de cette empathie justement
de se mettre à la place des individus de
l'époque et essayer de voir le monde tel
qu'ils ont pu le vivre donc à
l'imagination joue un rôle important
dans ce travail pour toucher le plus
grand public je crois à la nécessité
fondamentale de l'enseignement et de la
recherche
parce que en ce qui concerne l'
esclavage c'est l'histoire de
l'esclavagé est une histoire sans
archives donc on a besoin ou ont
pratiquement sans archives en tout cas
vous même vous avez travaillé sur des
archives oui oui oui mais mais pendant
cinq ans j'ai fait défection des
recherches pour retrouver notamment les
plaidoiries
le les traces de cet esclave qui avaient
fait 25 années de procédures dont on
n'avait même pas l'âge je veux dire le
quand je dis que c'est une histoire sans
archives je veux dire que il ya un an on
manque cruellement d'éléments dans
l'enseignement et la recherche s'en fout
fondamentaux mais c'est vrai que la
fiction l'art à part à apa rapporte
pardon cette dimension qui est un peu à
hauteur d'homme on parle à l'émotion et
les deux se complètent
merveilleusement bien la fiction et les
recherches on disait pour pouvoir faire
de l'affichage faut avant tout faire des
recherches oui justement il existe en
guadeloupe un centre de recherche qui
s'appelle le centre caribéen
d'expression des mémoires de la traite
et de l'esclavagé le mct on va voir un
reportage sur le rôle de ce centre
reportage de lys dollemard et rui aguas
10 mai 2015 moment solennel à pointe à
pitre en guadeloupe en présence de chefs
d'états caribéens et africains le
président de l'époque françois hollande
inaugure le mémorial acte centre
d'expression de la mémoire de la traite
négrière
aujourd'hui nous sommes rassemblés pour
évoquer le passé l'histoire
qui nous engage encore davantage pour
prévenir les fléaux qui nous menacent
[Musique]
cette idée de mémorial a longtemps été
porté par la société civile et
singulièrement par le comité
international des peuples noirs
depuis le bâtiment s'est imposée entre
autres comme un lieu de la vie
culturelle de l'opn
ici en avril 2022 l'artiste rosan monza
il donne un concert de gros cas il y en
a tant plu ce
père vivre ce lieu rendent encore plus
populaires
nous rien les mémoires à travers des
arts faire vivre le lieu c'est la tâche
de lorella reims ont ce jour là elle
recevait olivier guyonvarc'h ambassadeur
de france en jamaïque but de la visite
une meilleure coopération pour que la
jamaïque et la guadeloupe face histoire
commune
je trouverais peut-être extrêmement
intéressant de coopération entre le mat
et puis m'amuser jamais il n'y a pas de
musée de la piraterie en jamaïque le
monde nous regarde avec cette
institution sur ces question de
l'abolition de traiter brière avec
lavage que ce ne soit pas seulement
l'internement la dynamique globale
semble enclenché mais il reste du chemin
à parcourir au mémorial acte pour que
les huit de l'esclavagé devienne une
thématique majeure des sciences humaines
en guadeloupe comme dans le reste du
monde
[Musique]
franck salin pascal danel vous êtes tous
les deux bouts et de louper un alors
avec un peut-être chacun a un lien
particulier avec votre île d'origine est
ce que c'est important d'avoir ce centre
de recherche singulièrement en
guadeloupe oui c'est fondamental d'avoir
un ce mémorial acte
déjà parce que ça permet d'exposer cette
histoire parce que c'est vrai que
les historiens ont fait un travail
extraordinaire fait ces trente quarante
dernières années mais mais le l'intérêt
d'un musée c'est qu'on peut matérialiser
beaucoup de sujets avec des oeuvres
d'art des expos on peut faire organiser
des conférences des rencontres les
artistes peuvent s'y exprimer
parce qu'on en a besoin si deux objets
de rencontre pour faire vivre cette
histoire et
pour aussi
alors il faut il faut l'espérer qu'elles
soient moins
douloureuse qu'on n'en soit tout aussi
conscient mais qu'elle devienne moins
douloureuses parce que
aujourd'hui encore l' esclavage c'est un
sujet sensible au sujet
qui fait mal un sujet qui
[Musique]
revient quand il ya des tensions
aux antilles en guyane à la réunion
parce que certaines inégalités et
demeure certaine frustration certain
complexe demeure certains préjugés
demeurent donc le mémorial acte un rôle
vraiment très important à jouer et la
mission la mission immense oui tu n'es
15h55 dans quelques instants emmanuel
macron va arriver pour chapeauter
présidé cette cérémonie on va tout de
suite retrouvé martin bost maire dans
les jardins du luxembourg martin vous
êtes avec shimon shimon pardon aussi
mené schwarz barque
oui simone schwarz bart veuves dans les
schwarz bart dont un extrait du livre la
mulâtresse solitude sera lui tout à
l'heure et c'est même le thème retenu
pour cette cérémonie j'imagine que vous
ça vous touche particulièrement
bien sûr que ça me touche surtout que
l'écrivain qui a commis l'oeuvre n'est
pas présent et est parti un peu trop tôt
comme quoi
vivre assez longtemps ça nous permet
d'assister à des miracles est vraiment
et d'en profiter pleinement
vraiment oui il aurait aimé que cet
extrait soit lui aujourd'hui
en tous les cas il aurait vraiment été
content d'être là et d'entendre cette
lecture par des enfants
donc
le fait qu'il y ait la transmission par
ce biais ça l'aurait beaucoup touché je
pense
voilà le mot transmission aussi dans la
bouche de simone schwarz bart merci et
bonne cérémonie à vous merci martin
pascal danaë on parlait à l'instant de
la mulâtresse solitude dont j'avais
évoqué des graisses et en avant dans
cette émission c'est aussi une figure
guadeloupéen de la lutte contre
l'esclavagé
oui oui absolument c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs qui sait de figure parce
qu'il y ait une espèce de couple un
tandem comme ça qu'ils qui apparaissent
et tout ça c'est un peu il ya des choses
historique et puis yens part de fantasme
il ya des choses comme ça qu'on aime
rêver et la présence de cette femme-là
très cette femme forte aux côtés de la
grèce c'est quelque chose qui moi j'aime
beaucoup comme ça on penser à eux on
peut signaler d'ailleurs que la mairie
de paris inaugure ce soir dans le xviie
arrondissement une statue en hommage à
la très solide c'est sylvie daigle moi
j'aimerais qu'on vienne juste sur sur ce
reportage qu'on a vu juste avant martin
sur le mac quel bilan on peut vraiment
tirer de ce mémorial où qui a été
inaugurée par françois hollande en 2015
quel bilan vous vous en tirez est-ce que
c'est suffisant ce qu'il fallait faire
davantage peut-être un musée dans
l'hexagone dédié à ses mémoires à cette
histoire
alors ce qu'il faut toujours faire
davantage
il faut pas non plus enfin c'est aussi
très important que ce musée il soit dans
les dom parce qu'il ya toujours
justement quand on aborde cette question
il faut il faut à la fois faire des
choses dans les dom et dans l'hexagone
il faut pas que ce qu'on fait dans
l'hexagone mini ce qui existe déjà dans
les domaines sera donc c'est délicat et
l'autre question c'est que l'histoire de
l'esclavagé elle est aussi étroitement
liée à l'histoire de la colonisation la
colonisation elle persiste après
l'abolition de 1848 elle ne s'arrête pas
et à la départementalisation on peut
discuter de la situation postcoloniale à
l'heure actuelle donc en fait c'est pas
juste s'amuser des esclavages c'est un
musée de la colonisation et de
l'esclavagé dont on aurait besoin
éventuellement dans l'hexagone et qui
concernerait la période moderne comme la
période contemporaine et et tous les
continents où la france a colonisé des
territoires et des populations
il est question d'un monument dédié aux
esclaves c'est un une promesse d'
emmanuel macron au jardin des tuileries
nhs qui n'a pas pour l'instant été tenus
parce que retard diverses et variées ce
qu'on a besoin
ou 3 nous inviter la pascale st pascal
danaë parlons franck salin et mohammed
aïssaoui de ce type de monuments bien
sûr il faut un lieu de mémoire
ce qu'a réussi à faire la guadeloupe par
exemple l'île de la réunion n'a pas
réussi à le faire y avait un magnifique
projet qui c'est qui ça arrêtez de lieux
de mémoire et jeu tout est important
dans un tel sujet c'est à dire qu'il
faut des lieux de mémoire il faut de
l'enseignement il faut dollar et il faut
des questions ce que vous évoquez
bien sûr que
il faut des lieux mémoire là où ça s'est
déroulé parce que sinon ça devient
aberrant mais il faut aussi des lieux de
mémoire à nantes
à bordeaux et cetera à paris parce que
c'est un lieu central et je pense que
chaque
bâtiment j'allais dire est nécessaire à
l'édification de la mémoire sinon passez
à côté beaucoup il ya des blocages
aujourd'hui justement ouvert pour
instaurer ce genre de lieu de mémoire au
joli et dégâts il ya là quand cette
culture dont parle beaucoup avec toutes
ces histoires de déboulonnage de statut
est aussi c'est peut-être aussi un refus
de repentance dans certains secteurs de
la société vous ressentez vraiment les
blocages autour de toutes ces questions
oui puis avoir des blocages mais
certainement je pense que ce qui est
très important au delà des lieux de
mémoire je pense que c'est des crédits
des lieux de vie qui soit
joyeux alors je vais dire ça s'est fait
très important parce qu'en fait je
constate des blues
c'est très intéressant parce que j'en ai
parlé à une chambre avec tanaka qui
disent tiens vous faites du blues mais
quand on va à vos concerts c'est plutôt
joyeux ou à des champions qui s'éclate
guy roux c'est important parce que ça
fait vraiment partie d'ailleurs j'irai
de l'âme populaire et de la noire
peut-être cette manière d'exorciser le
mal est donc à travers la danse à
travers d'une manière comme ça de de
dépasser la douleur et quand je disais
c'est important de faire passer la
transmission aussi par la joie c'est une
manière de laisser entrer tout un chacun
y compris les gens qui sont pas
directement concernés par cette histoire
c'est une manière pour le d'entrevoir
quelques choses et de pouvoir à la suite
de ça être curieux et aller plus avant
donc créer des lieux de mémoire c'est
important mais ce que j'ai envie de dire
à tous les artistes tous ceux qui sont
actifs dans ce domaine s'est créé ont
surtout actuellement des oeuvres qui
voyagent crayon ddd lieu de oui de joie
de partage qui nous permette comme ça de
faire aussi un petit détour par la
mémoire parce qu'il ya beaucoup ça va
attirer pas mal de deux personnes c'est
jean-louis le l'esclavagé c'est un une
histoire douloureuse mais
heureusement les esclaves ont eu de
descendance je vous convie à l'image on
voit jean marc ayrault qui attend
effectivement avec le président du sénat
qui attend emmanuel marcon qui devrait
arriver d'une seconde à l'autre je vais
couper désolé oui le l'esclavagé est une
histoire douloureuse mais heureusement
les esclaves ont eu des descendants dont
moi et nous ne sommes pas
nous n'avons pas la réputation et nous
ne sommes pas des personnes
particulièrement triste et malheureuse
et donc luxe est vrai que le la mémoire
de l'esclavagé c'est la mémoire d'une
douleur mais fait aussi la joie
d'exister la joie d'être présent
aujourd'hui et moi je ne participe pas à
un mouvement dès le départ de
qui est celui du 23 mai et le 23 mai de
chaque année on organise on organise une
cérémonie et un concert qui s'appelle
ligne et bayod et des artistes viennent
chanter
donner de la joie c'est une fête de la
fraternité parce qu'il ya évidemment se
souvenir douloureux mais il ya la joie
de vie ou d'exister de partager cette
histoire avec tout le monde tous les 23
mêmes cette année c'est à saint denis
sur le parvis de la basilique à saint
denis il y à des artistes qui se
réunissent il ya une cérémonie et
j'aimerais d'ailleurs que le président
ou le premier ministre se déplace à
lille se déplace qui viennent le 23 mai
sur le parvis de la basilique de saint
denis pour participer à cette journée
nationale des victimes de l'esclavagé
parce que là on a deux dates le 10 mai
le 23 mai donc il faut qu'il participe
au 23 mai également que l'invitation est
lancée
et pour répondre à vos questions sur le
mémorial le mémorial oui pour moi tu es
c'est fondamental c'est il est porté par
des associations et ça pose une question
complexe emmanuel macron est en train
derniers jours donnent à parle tout de
suite mais on est en train d'arriver
donc dans ce jardin du luxembourg il est
accompagné de gérard larcher le
président du sénat et je croit
distinguer aussi au journal et au
président de la fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé
la cérémonie va débuter dans quelques
instants jour de la parole parce qu'ils
vous entendu franck salin emmanuel
macron donc
j'espère qu'il entendra parce que
sa fille a pendant plusieurs années il
ya eu des tensions pour la question des
dates
[Musique]
entrer dans la loi en 2010 cette célèbre
la mémoire victime donc il faut que le
gouvernement
et on regarde sur ces dates à parts
égales toujours sur l'image donc
emmanuel macron gérard larcher jean marc
ayrault est juste derrière la maire de
paris anne hidalgo et sébastien lecornu
le ministre d outre-mer qu'est ce que
vous attendez tous sur ce plateau de
cette cérémonie qui est un peu convenu
un disons le il va pas y avoir beaucoup
de surprises mais qu'est ce que vous en
attendez qu'elle est qu'est ce qu'elle
raconte cette cérémonie mon côté
optimiste c'est de dire qu'elle a nommé
la crise mais elle a vraiment le mérite
d'exister évidemment on aimerait
toujours un peu plus un discours sac ça
donne un peu plus de force mais elle
existe et on va s'appuyer pour les
présidents voilà on va s'appuyer sur
cette journée il ya eu des années fastes
un peu plus intéressante là on va voir
mais elle existe et voilà ça c'est quand
même important avec une loi à la clé
même question en pascal d'année cécile
est vital que ça fait quand même une
grande absente et christiane taubira qui
à l'origine de la loi dont on a fêté les
20 ans l'année dernière et nous dit on
est systématiquement invités chaque
année qui n'était pas très contente
l'année dernière de la façon dont la
cérémonie s'est déroulée à minima son
discours du président de la république
alors qu'il avait célébré la mémoire de
napoléon quelques jours auparavant et
qui n'est pas présent compris cette
année
disons c'est un contexte particulier
quand c'est vrai qu'elle a vraiment le
mérite d'exister tout à fait d'accord
c'est important moi quand j'ai quand
j'ai grandi avec pas de choses comme ça
on ne parlait pas c'était pas dans
l'espace public mais il ya un contexte
particulier il ya eu les élections c'est
vrai avec le
l'enracinement de certaines idées dans
la société française et donc ça mais on
relit encore davantage ce qui se passe
le fait que la dans l'espace public
encore une fois on on célèbre on
commémore l'abolition de l'esclavagé
alors qu'emmanuel ma couette en train de
visiter une exposition qui se trouve
dans le jardin du luxembourg une
exposition qui est chapeauté par la
fondation de la mémoire pour l'
esclavage 13 panneaux qui sont exposées
dans ce jardin esclavage et abolition
histoire de france c'est l'intitulé de
cette exposition dont un panneau
justement qui est consacrée à solitude
cette femme guadeloupéenne ancien
esclave sans que cela vous auriez mis
une prise de parole des manuels macron
puisque vous vous l'invité à participer
au 23 mai à vos côtés
moi je pense que le président doit
s'exprimer alors je ne sais pas qui
l'attend mais il doit s'exprimer le dit
mais il doit s'exprimer le 23 mai
le monument qui l'a promis jardin des
tuileries au jardin des tuileries bon il
a respecté un engagement de françois
hollande on fit briller encore le
gouvernement a promis érection
de ce monument il y avait une grande
assemblé aux archives nationales où le
ministre de la culture s'est engagé à
alléger son monument donc on l'attend
c'est bien que que l'état s'engage sur
ces questions mais il faut aussi qu'on
ait une parole forte
du président du premier ministre sur ces
questions donc qu'il reste silencieux
me pose question quand vous
l'interprétez alors je l'interprète de
plusieurs façons je me dis
je me dis qu'il qu'il entend qu'il a
peut-être entendu ce qui s'est passé aux
dernières élections où il est allé en
seconde position aux antilles en guyane
à la réunion
derrière le donc qu'il qu'il a peut-être
difficulté à
avoir
un discours clair à destination des
personnes originaires d'outre-mer la
question de du 10 mai du 23 mai doit
aussi
le faire réfléchir mais il faut pas
qu'il y avait lucie trop longtemps faut
aussi qu'ils s'expriment et il il est
une parole claire sur ces questions
d'autant que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'opposition à faire entre la mémoire
républicaine la république qui a eu de
grands hommes qui se sont battus pour
l'abolition et les esclaves qui se sont
battus pour leur survie pour pour être
libre ce ne sont pas forcément des
mémoires antagoniques donc je pense
qu'il y a moyen de trouver le discours
juste intelligent pour
exprimer la position de la france
aujourd'hui sur ces questions donc on
attend on attend
sa parole sur le sujet ces sites linden
être que le fait que notre président de
la république ne prennent pas la parole
ça dévalorise antho cette cérémonie
alors c'est regrettable qu'ils ne
prennent pas la page était important que
la cérémonie ait lieu de toute façon
quoi qu'il arrive et je dois dire que
moi enfin au delà de la cérémonie moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est ce que tout un
chacun fait autour de cette histoire de
7 mai - en fait plus que le regard de
l'état et l'action de l'état c'est la
manière dont la société civile dans son
ensemble
il me semble qu'il ya une demande en
fait pour cette histoire et cette
mémoire très partagés qu'on est que que
cette demande et enfin
les sociétés civiles française est
beaucoup plus est française dans le
ventoux sont dans tous les territoires
est beaucoup plus ouverte à cette
histoire beaucoup plus demandeuses que
notre classe politique qui a plus de mal
à assumer cette histoire et se passe et
que la bretelle générationnel peut-être
aussi oui peut-être mais pas seulement
en fait je pense que pour justement
avoir pas être parler devant des publics
très divers de tous les âges je pense
qu'il a
il ya un vrai intérêt
un vrai questionnement par rapport à
l'histoire de l'esclavagé de la
colonisation et
donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse en fait
c'est ce public ces publics divers et la
manière dont les gens sont part de cette
histoire la frilosité elle vient d'en
haut donc c'est pour ça ou davantage ou
et c'est pour ça que les artistes ont un
rôle à jouer en transmettant à leur
façon publique sans passer par par
l'état oui oui et les artistes
parlent avec leur coeur
bien sûr il ya ya ya l'importance de
lire moi moi c'est vrai que j'écris je
fais des films mais mais mais je lis
aussi les historiens
on a entendu aussi que voilà que
monsieur dana est aussi a pris le temps
de chercher de savoir qui était delgrès
semer ensuite il doit traduire traduire
tout ce qu'il a compris et ressenti dans
des chansons et c'est ça le travail
extraordinaire des artistes et les
artistes arrivent à toucher les gens
l'esprit mais aussi le coeur et c'est un
combat c'est un combat à mener parce que
pour pouvoir
vivre ensemble il faut se connaître et
beaucoup de personnes qui vivent en
france aujourd'hui sont
des descendants de coloniser d'esclaves
donc il faut que ce que notre qu'ils
soient soient connus mais est ce qu'ils
sont descendants de colons
de colons et de de négriers
doivent aussi prendre parti prendre part
à ce dialogue fois ci mais son histoire
il faut la regarder en face d'elle a
changé donc autant autant l'assumer
toujours à l'écran emmanuel macron qui
s'attarde sur cette belle exposition qui
se trouve au jardin du luxembourg qu'on
peut malheureusement pas visité parce
que le jardin du luxembourg a
complètement bouclée pour cette
cérémonie qui devrait débuter dans
quelques instants
maintenant cécile vidal parlais tout à
l'heure d'une appétence d'une désir de
savoir dans la génération vous ressentez
vous aussi ce désir de savoir
d'apprendre en savoir plus sur cette
histoire de l esclavage pas gelé
constaté après la publication mon livre
et surtout chez les jeunes
lycéens comme des collégiens j'ai vu
aussi par exemple que le livre va être
adapté au cinéma
etc abdelmalik qui va le réaliser donkey
issa sall a été possible que récemment
et j'ai justement ne rien imposer une
question assez vilain
de l'histoire d esclavage mais il ya
aussi j'aurais voulu que connaître kelly
lequel quelle est l'évolution de
l'histoire de la commémoration des
esclavages justement est ce que est ce
qu'on mémoire un peu plus est ce que
parce que j'ai le sentiment que quand
même il n'a pas il n'a pas beaucoup
existé de commémoration très longtemps
et que ça commence peut-être a évolué un
peu plus notamment la création de musées
etc ça oui et c'est un phénomène qu'on
retrouve
dans de très nombreux pays ou territoire
aux amériques en europe dans l'ensemble
de l'europe et en afrique également donc
c'est une histoire et puis il ya des
événements internationaux le l'unesco a
beaucoup joué on est dans la promotion
de cette histoire et de cette mémoire à
partir des années
1990 mais les choses s'accélèrent de
manière considérable - depuis que j'ai
commencé à travailler
il ya en effet une une une
visibilisation enfin rend visible cette
histoire et cette mémoire comme on ne le
faisait pas auparavant de multiples
façons ça devient une histoire légitime
ce qui n'était pas longtemps le cas à
l'université maintenant la tombe
sur l'amour travailler sur la france
signifie travailler sur l' empire
colonial oui et tenir compte à la fois
pour l'époque moderne du royaume et des
territoires d'outre-mer donc c'est
vraiment en train de changer très
rapidement et de 55 ans ça avance en
fait donc c'est assez passionnant de
observer ce qui se passe qui se
diffusent dans la société civile au-delà
de des domaines de recherche
purement historique oui absolument et
alors nous on a un rôle baisse conforme
les enseignants et on
on forme des gens en général mais ça se
fait de multiples façons par justement
la littérature par les arts par la
musique par les pièces de théâtre et
donc sa voix c'est multiples canaux en
fait le débat international aussi
de fait ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
au brésil dans la caraïbe a une
influence sur ce qui se passe dans
différents pays européens en afrique etc
donc c'est des mouvements maintenant
qu'ils sont à la fois nationaux et
internationaux et par l'arête ans vit à
lyon du rhony comme ça les a en ce
moment donc hausse atteint d'ici là qui
va abriter l instant on espère on voit
emmanuel macron qu'il était en pleine
conversation avec gérard larcher le
président du sénat toujours à cette
exposition qui assistent à cette
exposition organisée par la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé on
parlait de cette mémoire un peu partout
à l'international vous pascal delhay
vous faites des concerts j'imagine tout
voyagé beaucoup quand vous rencontrez
des gens aussi vous le sentez cette
curiosité à à l'étranger oui voyez des
gens ont vraiment envie d'en savoir plus
tout simplement parce qu en fait chacun
peut s'identifier
finalement à cette recherche de mémoire
de certaines personnes qui ont vécu une
période difficile en tant que peuple à
l'unité
parce qu'il suffit simplement de faire
référence à certains héros régionaux
voilà vous avez au canada par exemple
vous allez au pays cajun
voilà ou même d'autres partis dès que
vous êtes vous entré dans l'histoire un
peu plus intime de héros régionaux à la
d histoire douloureuse qui sont passés
les gens que d'un seul coup comprendre
un petit peu de vous venez et
s'identifier et donc c'est important de
pouvoir aller comme ça à travers le
monde et tu as raconté son histoire
parce que les gens aient un effet miroir
en quelque sorte il fait que les gens
peuvent s'associer à vous et c'est je
voulais en venir un petit peu sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure ce qui est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que au
niveau des individus s'il ya beaucoup de
plus de douze ouvertures effectivement
parce qu'ils peuvent s'identifier à des
à des douleurs intimes attendu que le
rôle du politique parfois c'est de tenir
tout le monde ensemble il ya une peine
peur de la dislocation et qu'on soit
plus une nation et là comme c'est un peu
le rôle il ya une peur qui va avec ça
qui fait que
il ya une forme d'inertie paralysie
alors qu'on voit emmanuel macron qui
arrive précisément maintenant sur les
lieux de la cérémonie et qui
dans la tribune si j'espère
prendre place dans la tribune alors faut
dire qu'en c1 un protocole qui souvent
très respecté c'est me limiterai à vous
avez dit que la cérémonie devait débuter
à 16h10 on a un tout petit peu de retard
mais ça devrait commencer dans quelques
instants on voit aussi gérard larcher le
président du sénat qui salue les membres
du gouvernement peut être l'une des
dernières images d'ailleurs de ce
gouvernement puisque on a en fait que ce
gouvernement doit aller jusqu'à la fin
du premier quinquennat à des manuels
vaqueront c'est-à-dire ce vendredi à
minuit il faut donc en profiter parce
que c'était la dernière fois pouvoir
certains ministres voilà je vous renvoie
et on a vu emmanuel macron s'entretenir
avec simone chars smart dont dont les
extraits du roman sont mariés la
mulâtresse solitude sera lue lors de
cette cérémonie qui est consacrée dédié
en tout cas à la mulâtresse solitude
héroïne de la lutte contre l'esclavagé
en guadeloupe et on voit aussi roger
karouchi le
vice-président du sénat alors que la
cérémonie je crois va débuter dans
quelques instants emmanuel macron est en
place jean marc ayrault est en place on
voit l'enjeu
gérard larcher
le corps de notre mère
chers invités cherche d'élèves qui pour
certains venaient de très loin vous
toutes et tous qui vivait en direct ce
moment dans les outre-mer et dans
l'hexagone bienvenue nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour la 17e cérémonie
officielle de la journée nationale des
mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions
cette commémoration marque une période
importante de notre histoire commune
elle nous permet de partager un moment
fort de transmission et surtout de
fraternité nous le faisons en réunissant
les générations et je salue la présence
aujourd'hui avec nos de près de 400
jeunes dont de toute la france le
programme de notre cérémonie sera le
suivant nous serons accompagnés par la
chanteuse madame christine salem
christine salem bien de la réunion elles
sont le blues elles sont le maloya une
musique née de la résistance à l'
esclavage
longtemps le maloya n'a pas eu droit de
cité dans cette île aujourd'hui il porte
un peu de l'âme de la réunion sa force
de résilience et son identité mais qui
sait et mélanger nous écouterons ensuite
la lecture de quatre textes rédigés par
les élèves de glace ayant participé aux
éditions 2020 et 2021 du concours
national de la flamme de l'égalité puis
nous entendons des extraits du roman
d'andré sparsbach la mulâtresse solitude
en hommage à cette figure cette femme de
guadeloupe devenue le symbole de la
résistance au rétablissement de
l'esclavagé par napoléon bonaparte en
1802 après une dernière chanson de
madame salem le président de la
république et le président du sénat
procéderont dépôt de gerbe devant le
monument le cri écrit créé par fabrice
hyber pour commémorer l'abolition de
l'esclavagé la cérémonie s'achèvera par
la marseillaise interprétées par la
chorale d'enfants les petits écoliers
chantants de bondy
et maintenant merci d'accueillir
chaleureusement madame christine salem
qui va nous interpréter en créole une
chanson de sa composition intitulée
merci c'est un bouc bienvenus
[Applaudissements]
mabri et malinkés
révolutionner dans la lumière pour
éclairer bail en martyr
des ti bercy
la ligne est un bon 10
[Musique]
malou ya
tout même pour guetta -
et
maloya
avait wa moins mme halimi ainsi bon g ou
la vaillant magie merci moore on met
dans ce cabaret
macabou cdh en chinois pour la nuit
banian autres maliens
mal à la lime
et
à l'uia
madonna ou
dans une cavale
et
maloya mon
magasin vie
pour vous
là où vent - sommet bayan la donne a
moins l'amour ôter la route
ou moins wavrinois un outil arômes au
bout - get d'intego banian
la garde la main
la moelle à dongo
oui il m'a dit merci mon
arrivée à st
bon on sait de long
qu'ils ont si vous me vie sens au mot
nagge à la boue
la moelle à dongo
oui m'a dit merci mon
tibia
moment cette langue
est moutète ou du nil et aux ego baba
qui sont robot femme l'amour lent
ok il tourne autour noter qu'au moins
aigri
home est un ciment
oui
maloya
à l'âge aux tirs
il crie aviva bas
et
maloya
la met à moins
tout en ligne et
maroc écrit en maraude vérité qu'on y
arrive kaba
magasin lui-même
maraude laly noté
bourguiba y en pour briller au go
[Musique]
pour g
et
maloya
ma danse house
dong à balan
et
mariam
a dans sa vie
pour grand mouvement
est remonté à outils ni les hanter goba
banque il son robot from la moue à la
hautaine
ituri tour noté
moins gai tri
home est un simon
et
maloya
madonna ou
dans une cabane
et
[Musique]
mariam ou
à grazailles
taupiac mieux
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
à
tbilissi
[Musique]
la ligne et à bondy
bien sûr il lancé
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez tout bleu
maintenant place à la transmission place
à la jeunesse elles nous viennent de
sotteville-lès-rouen elles sont dans la
classe de cm1 cm2 de madame labine de
madame la laiterie de madone bénard de
l'école élémentaire ferdinand buisson
j'appelle shirin ayachi sous vos
applaudissements
amélie fait bien six élèves de la classe
de la platé dole et règles élémentaires
l'édition de ma
part de l'égalité pour la flamme
d'égalité elles vont vous lire un
extrait de leur projet intitulé le
carnet de relever ce projet consiste en
un court métrage d'animation évoquant
plusieurs figures féminines de la
résistance à l'esclavagé de la liberté
bienvenue
chapitre 3 rubis et joséphine baker
j'aimerais connaître votre histoire j'ai
bien du sud des états unis j'ai eu une
enfance difficile il adorait danser et à
16 ans je suis parti pour new york car
c'était le meilleur endroit pour le
faire connaître j'ai réussi à être
rangés dans des petites attaques et là
j'ai rencontré des dames qui m'a emmené
à paris en france materis n'existait pas
la balle se dérouler plus tard la
première star noire de l'histoire
je suis impressionné et ensuite en 1939
je me suis engagé dans la résistance
jusqu à les casser de messages dans les
partitions mon copain ne s'est pas
arrêté là avec mon mari nous avons
adopté deux enfants d'origines
différentes je les ai appelés ma tribu
arc en ciel merci beaucoup de m'avoir
raconter votre histoire
[Musique]
il venait
alors pour les prochains d'élèves ils
ont fait plus de deux heures de vol pour
venir vivre ce grand moment avec vous
ils nous viennent de la réunion ce sont
les élèves de la classe de cm2 de madame
gang tôt et de matane la boulaye de
l'école élémentaire immaculée conception
de saint denis de la réunion ils sont
ici présents avec leur chef
d'établissement madame virassamy
j'appelle sur vos applaudissements
madame coeliaque honnêtement pas madame
tia koné dit pardon
[Applaudissements]
réel quel j il
soulève la glace lauréat
du prix spécial du jury vivre elle est
bien entendu du prix spécial du jury
2020 du concours de la flamme de
l'égalité ce projet prend la forme d'un
film d'une chanson et de textes écrits
par les élèves autour de la mémoire du
marronnage à la réunion ils n'ont lisent
les paroles de leur chanson intitulée
noir et marron et en créole c'est à vous
bien
[Musique]
owni
le monde
chalus kaboul un bouquet d'arbres ou de
charolles charroux les
chameaux chao janvier shao charge les à
coups de galets tandja bourgeois des
fous étaient des enchaînés dans le
calvados comme à niveau ont été mitigés
que le peu d'infos la mer c'est écrasant
maloya oublie la peur
j'avoue charles ou chanter
chan o cha mouche appelé les chameaux
pour charger
j'avoue charles jamais
toute la journée jusqu'à c'est moi ou
trika fait même à l'invitation des
crasses milon sadi groupe atic un coup
de fouet et et enchaîner le vote plus
fort la révolte et la cendre à mon
charme
j'avoue quai chaho charmant charmeur
chamoun chaouch argué
jamais jamais jamais
un forum internet fouquet où je mangeais
arrive le soir n'est pas d'accord
est ce bon quand tu animes de feu ça des
risques et je t'ai cache l2 pour gagner
la vallée secret
chacun
shabu shabu shabu shabu
shabu shabu shabu
le charme ont charmé or en dix ans à
d'abord la liberté oui car aucun doute
exploite bien engagée ni croire
conscience tout le courage benoît hamon
à celle où tous les gardiens la liberté
charles rocha beau chantier
shabu shabu shabu shabu
shabu shabu shabu
shabu chablais
[Musique]
nous
oui
moussa ronnement liberté où ça
heureusement liberté me fava ronnement
libère déjà bromont liberté et michard
rôle noir liberté où ça roule en liberté
rosemont liberté où sa robe aux libertés
nous ça
ça remet en liberté
[Applaudissements]
j'habitais
chabouk et en créole qui veut dire
frappé entre autres ils nous viennent de
bretagne les prochains ce sont les
élèves de classes de 4e de monsieur
prunier du lycée agricole jean baptiste
le taillandier de solaire et de 4e de
madame ménard du collège julien maunoir
de saint georges de reintembault
j'appelle sous vos applaudissements
dylan delaunay elia mi-mars
si on veut réaliser un projet artistique
commun intitulé du congo quillan go dans
le cas de l'édition 2021 du concours de
la flamme de l'égalité ils vont nous
interpréter un extrait de leur peau elle
zubi évocation d'un rebelle marron dans
le brasier du xviiie c'est à vous
le 6 on me voit son histoire et celle
des neuf ans ces histoires des pouliches
lave qui pour la liberté au mercy
instants avant l'arrivée au congo des
portugais mes parents vivent est libre
et monte à peu les zombies mon nom vient
d'une langue africaine qui signifie la
force de l'esprit mes parents étaient
rois du congo est heureux il vivait et
parents étaient capturés par les
portugais ils ont été emprisonnés ils
ont été maltraités ils ont été frappés
et pour les parents
les ont quitté le congo en bateau il
panique sur l'océan atlantique ils
étaient entassés beaucoup de morts
jetait à l'eau c'était des conditions
catastrophiques
je suis né libre mais par des soldats
portugais j'ai été capturé à 6 ans j'ai
été faits prisonniers lors d'une
expédition de braz darocha cardoso j'ai
été baptisé avait 15 ans francisco je
deviens le grand général en chef du team
ont beau pendant 14 ans j'ai été
considéré comme le plus vaillant des
guerriers en 1694 les portugais vous
voyez il aura en mai et des troupes
mercenaires ont conduites par domingo
vélo je me suis caché puis j'ai été
dénoncés j'ai été décapitée matin sur la
place publique a été exposée aujourd'hui
j'ai de nos moments dans plusieurs
villes des rues à sao paulo gloire à los
recife au brésil je suis soubie de ce
palmarès grand symbole de résistance
depuis
1995 le 20 novembre et célébrer le la
journée de la conscience noire
on doit tous les trois
alors direction l'est nous viennent de
l'académie de strasbourg ce sont les
élèves de la seconde de monsieur leopard
du lycée scheurer kestner
j'appelle souvent applaudissements bien
sûr lma à la julia dirait un à jamie
elles sont élèves de la classe lauréate
la catégorie glissé l'édition 2022 la
flamme de l'égalité elles vont nous lire
la conclusion de leur vidéo qui a pour
titre non l'esclave rage n'est pas
terminée mobilisons-nous ainsi de
l'expérience d'une jeune femme victimes
de l'esclavagé moderne en 30 ans 21e
siècle est là
l'histoire d'henriette retrace un combat
le combat de plus de 40 millions de
personnes sur cette falaise l'esclavagé
moderne toucher à la fois les adultes
les femmes mais aussi les enfants de la
mongole miat la mauritanie en battant
par les pays du moyen-orient et
d'afrique le droit de liberté des
humains et bas bruit
il est anormal qu'au xxième siècle on
recense encore des cas de travail forte
esclavage sexuel ou encore de traite
humaine notre beau pays la france n'est
pas épargnée par ce fléau on estime que
deux personnes sur mille sont victimes
d' esclavage moderne heureusement rien
n'est perdu des vins ganina des
organisations sont mises en place pour
sortir ces personnes de l'enfer elle
souhaite il clame le comité contre
l'esclavagé moderne ou encore le secours
catholique caritas
maintenant que vous êtes informés
parlez-en ouvrez les yeux et engagez
vous pour sauver ses esclaves des temps
modernes car après tout la quête de tout
humain c'est la liberté on rêve tous de
devenir libre
mais
est maintenant remercions les élèves des
classes lauréates elles ont été
effectivement nombreuses et leurs
professeurs pour la qualité du travail
réalisé et n'oublions pas les lauréats
des deux autres prix décernés en 2020
par le jury ils sont dans le public
aujourd'hui et je vais les citer mais
crier quand je parle de votre lycée au
collège de pavillons sous bois ce sont
les élèves de 1ere c'est ap menuiserie
de madame à louis ces professionnels est
nicolas ledoux les pavillons sous loire
merci qu'ils ont été mon reer ex-aequo
de la catégorie glissé de l'édition 2020
du concours pour leur lecture à haute
voix à théâtraliser intitulé bien sûr
hashtag devenir libre vous verrez on les
applaudit
ensuite vous n'êtes pas tout seul baghla
ce sont les élèves des classes de 5e 4e
3e de madame malte abily acier de madame
bello cas du collège ampère d'arles ils
sont lauréates 2020 de la catégorie
collège pour leur performance dansée
intitulé claveau allez-y vous convient
et
je vais inviter parmi eux idrissi brisé
sous vos applaudissements
samuel a créé 100 mais la retenue
ils vont nous lire deux extraits du
roman dans l'espace pas la mulâtresse
solitude bienvenue c'est à vous
en 1972 il ya 50 ans cette année
l'écrivain andré schwarz-bart publié à
paris un roman intitulé la mulâtresse
solitude
se livrent au pot sur un fait historique
en 1900 1802 lors des troubles en
guadeloupe entre le rétablissement de
l'esclavagé par bonaparte une femme a
été condamnée à mort
capturez enceinte en mai 1802 elle
n'exécutait que six mois plus tard après
avoir mis au monde son enfant
la légère si les archives nous disent
juste qu'elle s'appelait solitude et
qu'elle était métis qui était telle que
sont devenus ces défendant ce sont les
questions auxquelles andry farz à et sa
femme l'écrivaine guadeloupéenne simone
schwarz bart ont tenté de répondre dans
un cycle romanesque qui raconte
l'empreinte de l' esclavage sur la
société antillaise dans cet extrait
rosalie l'héroïne du roman révèle le
nouveau nom qu'elle fait souhaite
le met très dur le troupeau entièrement
nue sauf les jeunes mères qui retenaient
les locaux tour de laurent la rigoureuse
des commandeurs chanter un petit blanc
s'arrêta au bord de la route et 10 avec
la voie qu'ils ont pour dire ces choses
qui nous a tous fait ce qui signifie
comment t'appelles-tu mon enfant elle se
redresse à safia sur là où est il ce
rire le rire de ces personnes qui ne
sont plus là car elle navigue dans les
eaux de la perdition puis d'une voix
monocorde mais toujours traversé par le
sou même rire elle prononçait des
paroles qui devait s'attacher à n tout
au long de sa brève éternité avec la
permission mettre mon nom et solitude
par la suite je roman solitude traverse
tous les travers tous les événements de
la révolution en voie de l'application
de la pollution des esclavages brut et à
paris le cac remy 794 leur refus de
travail forcé les marrons anciens
esclaves anciens esclaves qui se sont
enfuis pour vivre libres
l'arrivée de troupes de bonaparte en
1802 la résistance muni par dell grèce
il n'y as pas l'air et leurs troupes
l'écrasement sanglant et leur révolte le
roman s'achève sur l'exigeant dessus de
solitude elle jours après son
accouchement devant une foule rassemblée
dans le phare qui porte aujourd'hui le
nom de la grèce à pointe à pitre
alors détournant son regard du baume à
drap contemplant le parterre des blancs
et prononcera très distinctement en un
excellent français de france dit ans qui
surpris toute l'assistance il paraît
qu'on ne doit jamais dire fontaine je ne
boirai le porno est renversant la tête
en arrière laissant les globes somptueux
de ses yeux fait tout bonnement par le
seigneur dit une légende pour refléter
les astres elle éclata en est curieux
rire de gorge par au coût le moins léger
entraînement à peine voilée de
mélancolie une sorte de chant très doué
sur lequel s'achève toutes les histoires
ordinairement tous les récits de rire
tous les comptes relatifs à la femme
solitude de bois de l'autre
un peu gâché leur vie n'est prévu
nous allons maintenant retrouver madame
christine salem qui va nous interpréter
une dernière chanson de sa composition
intitulée tholot et qui risque d'être
émouvante et avant de l'applaudir pour
l'encourager
et
la norvège et l'assaut et dans l'eau
manning et dingo sur la scène
et dans le
rouge et
dans le
[Musique]
latium bedie au moment
où gay dans l'homélie ghellab aux
aidants somme après 10 et landon
d'angola ça y est
non mieux regrette pas non non non non
non non non il regrette padang
et dans l'eau
et dans ce triangle
avouer ni
n'avait point de l'eau nous l'a donnée
n'avait pas au lobby poids lourds nous
la donner de l'eau à la donne
j'avais moins de launois données avait
pas de l'eau la vie padulo noah ne les
avait pas de l'eau de nos
mémoires
comme à lille on est là pour gagner
alors mon sommeil
ça va loin
15e sont fiers
tu as oublié
je t'aime à prier santé pour arroser
regardez pas de launois données les
poids lourds nous l'a donné à vélo
avaient foi de l'oni la lune et avait
pas l'eau avait faim de loup n'y avait
pas d'eau a largué
matin regrette pas
à louer à prix oumarou mais c'est
l'inversé
vendée
qatar où la lumière jean d'illac les
dégâts étaient
tu avais pas de nous la donner avait pas
d'eau a vu poids lourds nous la donner
avait pas de l'eau à la bouche et moi ne
tomba malade
fondamentale pas
à me plaindre nous a donné avec de l'eau
la vie pas toujours nous adonner à des
frais de l'eau de tronquer moins de
trois mois de combats
à la frontière
michael macht a dû rouler au pas
[Musique]
la donne mon patin durerait pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président de la république
c'est le président du sénat je vous
invite maintenant à procéder au dépôt de
gerbes qui sera suivi d'une minute de
silence et de l'interprétation de
l'hymne national par la chorale les
petits écoliers chantants de bondy
mesdames et messieurs merci de bien
vouloir vous lever
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
contre nous
allez
[Musique]
encore
m
[Musique]
non
voyant
hormis
[Musique]
ah bon
nyon
nous entrerons dans l'ariège
des coûts
onzième à pas
[Musique]
galtier
la mêlée
m
[Musique]
et
toi rien
on est
athènes
marchand
[Musique]
sion
nous y voilà
un foyer
masson
[Musique]
si long
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour cette cérémonie de jardin du
luxembourg ce 10 mai
officialisée par emmanuel macron bas
juste avant de se retrouver pour un
premier sentiment de nos invités sur
cette cérémonie dire au revoir aux
téléspectateurs de réunion la première
qui nous ont suivis on va les quitter
parce que c'est l'heure du journal
télévisé à la réunion mais ceux qui
souhaitent peuvent continuer à nous
suivre sur le portail de la première
point fr
premières impressions donc ses cibles
idéales sur cette cérémonie
moi ce qui m'a beaucoup trop juste et
évidemment les interventions des enfants
et le fait qu'elles portaient
sur des sujets très différents et sur
des territoires très différent de
l'esclavagé colonial à l' esclavage
moderne
les territoires colonisés par la france
au brésil et il me semble que ça dit
bien que l'histoire de l'exclavage et
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est une
histoire qui nous concerne tout ce qu'on
peut s'approprier de différentes façons
depuis différents lieux et faire écho
voilà donc c'est pour ça je trouve que
la cérémonie était oui en effet assez
nouveau voilà ici oui je partage
vraiment ce que vous dites sur cette
diversité des témoignages d esclavage au
sens vraiment le plus large possible
même contemporain moderne
j'en étais très émue moi j'ai un j'ai
toujours un pincement au coeur quand
j'entends simone schwarz bart et que je
pense aussi à andré schwarz qui est qui
avait eu le goncourt pour son premier
roman le dernier des justes qui portait
sur la shoah et ont eu à l'époque on lui
avait reproché
d'avoir parlé des deux je sais pas
comment appeler sa tragédie de
l'histoire l'esclavagé et la shoah et
aujourd'hui on voit à quel point il ya
une telle avancée et c'est dommage que
des
des êtres comme
qu'il existe au moins mais j'aimerais
bien
savoir exactement mais c'était une
cérémonie touchante en tout cas par la
part la présence des enfants notamment
parce qu'elle est mais j'irai dans votre
sens effectivement la présence des
enfants la part importante qu'ils ont
prise dans mes quatre enfants total ep
très dynamique la façon qu'ils ont
abordé des chaussettes et des des
passages assez court à ces impacts ans
et on sentait que c'était très ému ça
m'a beaucoup touché et puis évidemment
tant que musiciens la musique la
prestation
que je connais et que j'apprécie
voilà c'était très touchant aussi
d'entendre le texte en créole je connais
pas le créole réunionnais je comprends
pas mais j'étais très touché par ce très
jeune et parle très forte très à la fois
dit de manière douce comme vraiment dire
on aurait dit du blues la première
partie oui de son chant et des paroles
fortes la liberté c'est important pour
moi je connaissais pas le mariage je
l'admets c'est c'est un chant qui c'est
un genre musical qui est né à la réunion
je vois qui est aujourd'hui inscrit au
patrimoine culturel de l'humanité c'est
important aussi de préserver ses champs
c'est important oui parce qu'en fait
c'est un lien direct j'irai avec la
terre-mère on sent vraiment la présence
africaine à travers l'utilisation
pratiquement exclusive de tambours
c'était vraiment un moyen pour les
esclaves de retrouver de garder un lien
avec leurs racines et que le fait que
cette musique est que ce lien là puisque
ait pu perdurer à travers le temps c'est
très important surtout sachant qu'à une
époque c'était interdit et moi j'irai je
me souviens de mon père qui était né en
1915 qui parlait de la musique du gros
cadeau qui l'équivalent du maloya la
guadeloupe à musique à base de tambours
à la martinique et le beller et c'est de
musique là c'était considéré comme on
disait musique aviez c'est à dire
la musique d voilà des fallait pas
écouter ça et maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui est revendiqué que les gens
jouent tous les jours c'est très
important ça c'est le lien avec les les
racines les origines et où est né le
blues dans les champs
avec une grande partie
c'est toujours la tentative même le
blues des origines et c'était toujours
un moyen pour les afro-américains de
garder ce lien avec les racines
africaines franck ça la regarde
moi le
la cérémonie ce qui m'a marqué fait
effectivement la présence des enfants et
il faut que les enfants via les écoles
via leurs parents s'approprient cette
histoire ce qui m'a manqué aussi c'est
le silence des représentants de l'état
de la république ni le président du
sénat non dit le moindre mot
alors qu'il y a tant à dire alors
j'espère que le 23 mai un mot sera 10
mai mais je pense qu'il faut il faut il
faut il faut qu'on les entendre sur ces
questions
surtout après les mois qu'on vient de
passer conserver une minute de silence
symbolique ça c'est pas suivre non non
il faut il faut qu'il s'exprime il faut
aussi qu'ils s'expriment bien sûr sur
sur l'histoire et sur les symboles mais
mais cette histoire et ses symboles soit
en lien avec nous aujourd'hui ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui donc donc moi je me vois
bien aimé les entendre c'est sylvie nage
vers question qui va pas forcément dans
votre sens fonctionner parce que c'est
vraiment politique de s'insérer dans ce
sens cette histoire mémorielle dans
cette histoire de l esclavage ça doit en
faire partie solaire c'est tout le monde
mais le parler de l'histoire la mémoire
de l'esclavagé parler du présent et des
héritages en fait de cette histoire est
donc malheureusement d une égalité des
violences de discrimination qui persiste
c'est toujours en fait les politiques
ont tendance à regarder cette histoire
pour créer du consensus mais en fait
c'est plutôt en fait un moyen de révéler
les débats les tensions les dix insu ce
qui sont au coeur de la démocratie donc
en fait c'est simple lot tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer en exprimant des
points de vue contradictoires y compris
en reprochant au président de la
république et au président du sénat ne
pas prendre la parole lors de ces
cérémonies donc je pense que c'est voilà
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est les
débats qu'on a autour
chaque fois qu'on évoque cette question
et la manière dont ça permet justement
de deux essayez d'imaginer un
meilleur futur en fait on va faire un
petit tour du côté du jardin du
luxembourg pour retrouver martin bost
maire qui est toujours avec nous merci
martin et cette cérémonie qui s'achève
avec le départ donc les manuels macro
est peut-être un regret celui de ne pas
avoir entendu la parole du président de
la république sur ce sujet
oui forcément forcément c'était c'était
attendu qu'emmanuel mâcon prennent la
parole mais en même temps c'était tout
aussi attendu car on était prévenu qu'il
ne la prendrai pas pendant cette
cérémonie il ya quelque chose d'assez
marquant ses cris n'allons tout le monde
est resté très silencieux une sorte de
solennité pour écouter les élèves
notamment au moment de la marseillaise
des des jeunes élèves de bondy vous
savez les jeunes ça a tendance à sortir
son téléphone portable etc ça c'en est
un petit peu mais là pas du tout le
monde va écouter de manière très très
solennelle et les différentes
interventions des différentes lectures
les différents champs ce qui marque par
rapport à l'année dernière derrière
c'est que immédiatement après la fin de
la cérémonie emmanuel macron avait eu
une sorte de bonnes foules il avait
parlé à tout le monde il avait rencontré
les élèves là tout le monde reste reste
en place les différents ministres qui
sont dans la tribune juste à côté reste
en place et attendent qu emmanuel macron
et discuter finalement avec les les
élèves le chef de l'état qui qui doit
encore échanger ça aussi c'était prévu
et ensuite il va il va repartir et à ce
moment-là peut-être qu'on aura une ou
deux réaction après cette cérémonie
merci beaucoup martin essayer d'avoir le
micro notre plaisir ça très bien à
franck salin ici sortir les taux mais
pas seulement évidemment on a vu cette
cérémonie était consacrée à la jeunesse
jeunesse clairement il faut s'adresser à
cette jeunesse celle qui la reprend le
flambeau de cette mémoire aujourd'hui
peut-être oui la transmission c'est
évidemment la jeunesse mais c'est aussi
le travail des professeurs
j'ai vu aussi que par exemple quand
j'étais allée lieu de la réunion il est
même qui connaissent bien le sujet de l'
esclavage parce qu'ils sont touchées
près les professeurs n'avaient pas
d'outils pour parler
aux élèves de l'esclavagé ce qu'on peut
dire le mot par exemple sans
blesser un enfant et c'est donc tout ça
cette idée de transmission il faut
qu'elles émanent de partout bien sûr
qu'elle s'adresse à la jeunesse mais les
adultes aussi beaucoup ne savent pas
grand-chose de l' esclavage mais
transmettre sans repentance sans
culpabilité non plus important dans
l'autre groupe dell grèce où on est roi
il ya bâtisse bondi le batteur qui est
nantais depuis des générations il ya un
parisien rapti qui lui a été confié au
wall ou pour la plupart du temps voilà
c'est vraiment le vivre ensemble est
avancé à partir de là mais c'est très
important de de savoir effectivement de
faire face a acquis on est à son
identité je pense qu'il ya aussi un
élément qui est important et qui tuent
fille joue en quelque sorte parce qu'on
a ces discussions entre nous c'est les
origines de l'esclavagé nous n'oublions
pas que il s'agit toujours
d'exploiter quelqu'un dans un but de
profit et je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est sous jacent et qui va en
fait qui m'unit afrique finalement les
gens qui y ont subi l'esclavagé à
travers les âges c'est bel et bien à un
moment une manière de pensée qui est
l'accaparement des richesses par voilà
un groupe de personnes autres au
détriment d'un autre personne donc c'est
cette manière de penser qui
malheureusement a mais encore
aujourd'hui la persistance de toutes
formes d'esclavagé d'exploitation pionne
aille à cette cérémonie du 10 mai qu'on
vient de vivre questions ouvertes un peu
à chacun d'entre vous qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire aujourd'hui pour aller
plus loin dans cette mémoire dans cette
histoire de l' esclavage pour
transmettre précisément
pour aller plus loin il ya plusieurs
choses à faire il ya déjà tout tout le
travail que doivent faire les
descendants d'esclaves
de s'approprier et d'assumer leur
histoire que ce ne soit plus une honte
qu on entende plus à nommer ça ça n'a
pas existé où ça a été une parenthèse ou
où certains descendants d'être la fille
diane au moins je suis descendant de roi
ou de reine africains ou européens
d'esclaves à genoux ça je veux content
de parler de ça donc déjà assumé cette
histoire-là l'accepter
ou
non mais de mieux de mieux en mieux on
accepte de plus en plus comparé à ce que
moi j'ai vu entendu vécu enfant faut
reconnecter à des progrès énormes qui
ont été faites ça ça c'est formidable
mais aussi dans cette société pour les
noms descendants d'esclaves il faut
accepter d'entendre d'apprendre cette
histoire parce que c'est une histoire
partagée c'est pas c'est pas que la
mienne
c'est celle de tout le monde sait ça
fait partie de l'histoire de france
histoire du monde et il faut que tout le
monde et tu dis après cette histoire et
puis le travail que font les artistes
qui ont toujours été des pionniers sur
ces questions
avec le soutien l'aide bien sûr des
historiens est important mais vraiment
le pour moi le le le le plus important
c'est que les descendants
assume cette histoire en face leur
généalogie
accepte qu'ils sont voilà pour moi c'est
vraiment le la clé c'est celle vidal la
clé c'est justement tout le monde
s'empare de cette histoire on a parlé en
début d'émission des professeurs des
jeunes des artistes avec nos invités sur
ce deuxième plateau il faut que tout le
monde sans fin de cette histoire pour en
faire une histoire commune oui
absolument et donc le la clé c'est
vraiment la manière d'intégrer cette
histoire à l'histoire nationale voilà
l'histoire européenne
c'est pas d'en faire des histoires
séparées d'en faire une histoire qui est
importante mais qui serait distincte
c'est vraiment en fait d'écrire une
autre histoire
de france l'aider territoire sous
souveraineté française mais aussi
démontré atlantique en général du monde
en général donc ça ça me paraît vraiment
essentiel sait faire c'est faire nation
c'est faire citoyenneté commune que sans
parler tous ensemble de cette histoire
absolument ça contribue mais en effet
pas forcément avec un sol hristina
sionnel moi je suis l'idée qu'il ait
qu'une seule interprétation mais laissé
la porte ouverte eu justement
à des débats sur ce qu'est l'histoire de
france comment dois l'écrire
comment doit l'interpréter
voilà c'est ça qui me paraît le plus
important c'est le fait d'en être
capable d'en parler ensemble il nous
reste exactement une minute peut-être
face qu'à donner mohammed aïssaoui si
vous aviez un mot aujourd'hui pour notre
jeunesse
à propos de cette histoire qu'on
aimerait transmettre
créer ou créer des choses à
regarder regarder qui on est en face et
à partir de là créé parce que créer
c'est ce qui va permettre aux autres de
vibrer et à partir de là tout est
possible en paréo cette histoire
microsoft
bah ça sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
d'avoir accepté notre invitation d'avoir
suivi avec moi cette cérémonie cette 17e
cérémonie de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
on avait beaucoup de responsables
politiques beaucoup de membres du
gouvernement s'étaient peut-être la
dernière fois d'ailleurs qu'on les a vus
puisque le gouvernement castex on en
parlait tout à l'heure devrait rester en
place jusqu'à vendredi ce vendredi
minuit emmanuel macron à participer à
cette cérémonie mais pas de discours
dommage on disait tout à l'heure dommage
pour nous dommage pour les observateurs
pour les historiens peut-être aussi pour
les populations d outre-mer merci à vous
d'avoir votre écran merci d'avoir suivi
cette cérémonie merci ces liens merci
steve et merci à nos invités merci à
martin bost maire qui était avec nous
depuis les jardins du luxembourg
rendez-vous donc l'année prochaine avec
un nouveau personnel politique à très
bientôt
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]